Tasha: 怪不得给你哦
Tasha: No wonder she gave it to you.
Jake:所以他所以你很懂是吧
Jake: So, you really know a lot, huh?
Tasha: 是你吗是你断了那条吗不是你
Tasha: Was it you? Did you break that piece? Not you?
其他人：断了那条
Others: That one's broken.
Jake:不是他的
Jake: It's not his.
Jake:修硕修硕断的
Jake: Shure broke it.
Jake:哦哦水切对
Jake: Oh, oh, water cut, right.
Lucia: 忒难用
Lucia: This is so hard to use.
Jake:我来帮你看看怎么办
Jake: Let me help you figure it out.
其他人：剪成这个样子是吧
Others: Cut it like this, right?
Jake:他这个就是掉了嘛
Jake: It just fell off.
其他人：啊我知道
Others: Ah, I see.
Jake:可以啊开始
Jake: Okay, let's start.
Lucia: 另外那个剪刀在哪里
Lucia: Where's the other pair of scissors?
Jake:另外我也没找着
Jake: I couldn't find it either.
Lucia: 实在是太不好修了
Lucia: It's really hard to fix.
Jake:学生小菜刀
Jake: Student's small knife.
Jake:小剪刀目测一下
Jake: Small scissors, eyeball it.
其他人：目测一下
Others: Eyeball it.
其他人：这个圈口
Others: This ring size.
其他人：53
Others: 53.
Tasha: 不是
Tasha: No.
其他人：48
Others: 48.
Tasha: 哪有这么小
Tasha: 你没有你没有
Tasha: No, you didn't, you didn't.
Tasha: 你没有数是吧
Tasha: You didn't count, right?
其他人：56
Others: 56
Tasha: 差不多
Tasha: Close enough.
其他人：刚刚前两条是在试探你
Others: We were just testing you with the first two.
Tasha: 我一看你的手围我就知道54左右
Tasha: As soon as I saw the size of your hand, I knew it was around 54.
其他人：啊你才是专家
Others: Ah, you're the expert.
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Jake:又被秀了
Jake: Got showed up again.
其他人：我根本不知道我多少
Others: I have no idea what mine is.
Tasha: 54
Tasha: 54.
其他人：真的吗
Others: Really?
Tasha: 嗯真的
Tasha: Yeah, really.
Jake: 不会不会不会
Jake: No way, no way, no way.
Tasha: 54就行
Tasha: 54 is fine.
其他人：行家行家啊
Others: Expert, expert!
Jake:呃最好对对对
Jake: Uh, the best, yeah, yeah.
其他人:你是经常买还是现在刷短视频
Others: Do you buy often or just watch short videos now?
Tasha: 哈哈哈我我是经常买
Tasha: Hahaha, I buy often.
其他人: 经常买比较实用
Lucia: 感觉我像机器人似的还要卷卷
Lucia: I feel like a robot, still have to hustle.
其他人: 卧槽富婆我不想努力了
Others: Damn, rich lady, I don't want to work hard anymore.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Lucia: 这个真难用
Lucia: This is really hard to use.
Jake:这个撕不开
Jake: This can't be torn open.
Jake:也还行吧
Jake: It's alright.
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
Lucia: 来捏捏给他塑个形
Lucia: Come on, squeeze it and give it some shape.
Jake:我看一看
Jake: Let me take a look.
Jake:海关如果没把我镊子给收了
Jake: If customs hadn't taken my tweezers.
Jake:我现在就能用
Jake: I could use them now.
Jake:就是海关把我
Jake: But customs took my...
Jake:呃就是就是
Jake: Uh, they took my...
Jake:那那那螺丝刀
Jake: That, that, that screwdriver.
Jake:里边有很细的那种
Jake: There was a very fine one inside.
Jake:这个还行吧
Jake: This one's alright.
Alice:没有这个
Alice: Not this one.
Alice:原味是最好吃的
Alice: The original flavor is the best.
Jake:试试试试看
Jake: Try it, give it a go.
Jake:看疼不疼
Jake: Check if it hurts.
Jake:如果疼我们再包一层
Jake: If it hurts, we'll wrap it again.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Lucia: 没事没事这样应该可以
Lucia: It's fine, it's fine. This should be okay.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Alice:这是岫玉
Alice: This is Xiu jade.
Alice:不是翡翠
Alice: It's not emerald.
Alice:就不在你那个评价体系里面
Alice: So it's not in your evaluation system.
其他人:也是一个董哥
Others: It's also from Jack.
Alice:确实先这样吧
Alice: Let's just leave it like this for now.
Lucia: 先这样吧
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Alright.
Lucia: 错过一下
Lucia: Let it pass.
Lucia: 但是我又需要一双眼镜布
Lucia: But I need a glasses cloth.
Tasha: 哎我刚才用了眼镜布
Tasha: Oh, I just used the glasses cloth.
Jake:怎么都乱扔东西了
Jake: Why is everyone just tossing things around?
Jake:我我我对不起对不起
Jake: I, I, I'm sorry, sorry.
Jake:我乱扔蒜
Jake: I tossed the garlic.
其他人:算什么
Others: Tossed what?
Alice:什么算什么
Alice: What do you mean tossed what?
其他人: 也是开石头的吗
Others: Are you also cracking stones?
Tasha: 也是开石头
Tasha: Also cracking stones.
其他人:你开过石头吗
Others: Have you cracked stones before?
Tasha: 我没开过石头
Tasha: I haven't cracked stones before.
其他人:我怎么说我
Others: How about I
其他人:我就给你几块石头你看一看
Others: How about I give you a few stones to check out?
Jake:哼哪里有啊
Jake: Huh, where are they?
Tasha: 我不会挑石头
Tasha: I'm not good at picking stones.
Tasha: 我会挑榴莲
Tasha: I can pick durians.
Tasha: 挑石头还得再练几年
Tasha: Picking stones takes a few more years of practice.
其他人:我便宜卖你
Others: I'll sell them to you cheap.
Alice:哈哈哈我晚上去挑一个
Alice: Haha, I'll go pick one tonight.
其他人:我晚上去挑一个
Others: I'll go pick one tonight.
Tasha: 善哥您是要开始想做蛋糕是吗
Tasha: Shange, are you planning to make a cake?
其他人:对啊
Others: Yeah.
Tasha: 您先把这个洗了吧
Tasha: You should wash this first.
其他人:哪个
Others: Which one?
Tasha: 就这个
Tasha: This one.
其他人:这个
Others: This one?
Tasha: 哈哈哈都要都要
Tasha: Haha, all of them, all of them.
其他人:您确定要用这个
Others: Are you sure you want to use this?
其他人:哈哈不用就可以不洗
Others: Haha, if you don't use it, you don't have to wash it.
Tasha: 哦那那用的就这个吧
Tasha: Oh, then let's just use this.
其他人:我帮你洗了你一会得教我点真东西
Others: I'll wash it for you, but you have to teach me something real later.
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha
其他人:教我点假东西
Others: Teach me something fake.
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Okay.
Tasha: 教你点假的
Tasha: I'll teach you something fake.
其他人:天天教我假的
Others: You always teach me fake stuff.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahaha
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahaha
Tasha: 你有一天学过吗
Tasha: Have you ever learned anything?
Tasha: 你知道他都学多少了吗
Tasha: Do you know how much he has learned?
Tasha: 你都跟不上他了哈哈哈
Tasha: You can't keep up with him, hahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahaha
Jake:怎么能上去
Jake: How can we get up there?
Alice:写经在楼上吗
Alice: Is the scripture upstairs?
Jake:给你瞅一个
Jake: Let me show you.
其他人:昨天学了
Others: Learned it yesterday.
其他人:昨天学金铲铲啊
Others: Yesterday, I learned about the golden shovel.
其他人: 金铲铲你也学会了吧
Others: You learned about the golden shovel, right?
Tasha: 你也学会了吧
Tasha: You learned it too, right?
Lucia:我学会了
Lucia: I learned it.
其他人:我看我看一遍我
Others: Let me see, let me see.
其他人:做今天来做肉松小贝鸡蛋
Others: Today, we're making pork floss cupcakes and eggs.
其他人:这是多少
Others: How many is this?
其他人:这是几个
Others: How many are these?
其他人:6个
Others: Six.
其他人：武林秘籍
Others: Martial arts secrets.
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha
其他人:为什么糖是5块钱
Others: Why is the sugar 5 yuan?
Lucia:武林秘籍
Lucia: Martial arts secrets.
其他人:加到面对一斤面粉
Others: Add it to a pound of flour.
Tasha: 对
Tasha: Right.
其他人:准备找他
Others: Get ready to find him.
其他人:准备就是昨天晚上准备问他要啊
Others: We were ready to ask him last night.
其他人:他说要收我3,000块
Others: He said he would charge me 3,000 yuan.
其他人:我想想算了
Others: I thought, forget it.
其他人:一块混到一起
Others: Mix it all together.
Lucia:武林秘籍才卖你3,000块
Lucia: The martial arts manual only costs you 3,000 bucks.
Lucia:还嫌贵哈哈
Lucia: And you still think it's expensive, haha.
其他人:我说打折价
Others: I meant the discounted price.
Tasha: 你可以在新加坡独步天下了
Tasha: You can dominate the world in Singapore with it.
Lucia:哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Alice:你3,000买的秘籍
Alice: You bought the manual for 3,000.
Alice:你300卖出去
Alice: And you sell it for 300.
Alice:你卖100 你净赚
Alice: If you sell it for 100, you make a profit.
Lucia:你可以做成做成电子版
Lucia: You can make it into a digital version.
Lucia:然后就是以300块钱卖电子版
Lucia: And then sell the digital version for 300 bucks.
Lucia:你可以卖无数个
Lucia: You can sell countless copies.
Lucia:一本万利啊
Lucia: A huge profit!
Lucia:哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Tasha: 那个的话
Tasha: In that case...
Tasha: 用厨房纸巾擦会擦的更干净点
Tasha: Using kitchen paper will clean it better.
其他人:你要用哪个
Others: Which one do you want to use?
Tasha: 在楼上就用这个
Tasha: If it's upstairs, just use this one.
其他人:就用这个
Others: Just use this one.
Jake:厨房纸巾
Jake: Kitchen paper.
Lucia:什么厨房纸
Lucia: What kitchen paper?
Lucia:在楼上吗在楼上
Lucia: Upstairs? Is it upstairs?
Jake:在楼上吧
Jake: Probably upstairs.
Jake:找找去
Jake: Let's go find it.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
其他人:你要在这做就在这
Others: If you want to do it here, then do it here.
Tasha: 就在这呀
Tasha: Do it here then.
Jake:二楼煎牛排
Jake: Grilling steak on the second floor.
Jake:二楼开火
Jake: Cooking on the second floor.
其他人:哎那我是不是要煎牛排
Others: Wait, does that mean I have to grill the steak?
Jake:你你可以煎牛排
Jake: You can grill the steak.
Jake:也可以或者你也
Jake: Or you can also...
Tasha: 这些杯子都拿走吧
Tasha: Take all these cups away.
Jake:你也可以先和和面
Jake: You can also start by kneading the dough.
Jake:然后再去煎牛排
Jake: Then go grill the steak.
其他人:戴个眼镜
Others: Put on glasses.
其他人:煎牛排
Others: Grill the steak.
Tasha: 这些杯子拿走
Tasha: Take these cups away.
Tasha: 他很危险
Tasha: It's dangerous.
Jake:眼镜我可以站你旁边给你拍
Jake: Glasses, I can stand next to you and take pictures.
Lucia:这也没找着啊
Lucia: We still can't find it.
其他人:谁出来玩还多东西
Others: Who brings so much stuff when going out to play?
其他人:那不好说
Others: That's hard to say.
其他人:人家给你准备用钱
Others: They're probably ready to spend money.
Alice:谢谢你
Alice: Thank you.
Tasha: 你还知道把它擦干啊
Tasha: You actually knew to wipe it dry?
其他人：这还能不知道吗
Others: How could I not know that?
其他人:他他他对你说话的语气好轻蔑
Others: The way he talks to you is so condescending.
其他人:你要反击他
Others: You need to fight back.
Tasha: 没有没有
Tasha: No, no.
Tasha: 我是我是说他居然知道这个
Tasha: I mean, I'm surprised he even knows that.
Tasha: 做甜品是需要无油无水的
Tasha: Making desserts requires no oil and no water.
Lucia:哦好厉害啊
Lucia: Oh, impressive!
Lucia:你说的是那种吸水纸吧
Lucia: You're talking about those absorbent papers, right?
Lucia:但是我们只找到了这个
Lucia: But we only found this.
Tasha: 这个这个吗
Tasha: This one?
Lucia:在那啊OK
Lucia: There it is, okay.
Jake:好的
Jake: Got it.
Lucia:我还以为那个在楼上
Lucia: I thought it was upstairs.
Lucia:我就记得你好像买了一卷这个
Lucia: I just remember you bought a roll of this.
Jake:先打过来
Jake: Just send it over first.
Lucia:那个那个超好用
Lucia: That one is super useful.
Lucia:特别好用
Lucia: Especially useful.
其他人:只要一摔了就不好摔了
Others: Once it falls, it's hard to use.
其他人:应该拿上毫无生活经验的标签
Others: It should come with a "no life skills" label.
其他人::哈哈哈你这个把为什么这么短
Others: Haha, why is this handle so short?
其他人:我觉得很难很难拿
Others: I find it very hard to use.
Tasha: 这把为什么这么短
Tasha: Why is this handle so short?
Tasha: 是的呢要不你去让厂家生产改一下
Tasha: Yeah, maybe you should ask the manufacturer to change it.
其他人:好你买的
Others: Fine, you buy it.
其他人:不对好你买的
Others: No, fine, you buy it.
Tasha: 好你买的肯定比我好
Tasha: Fine, you buy it, it'll definitely be better than mine.
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Jake:尬住了尬住了尬住了
Jake: This is awkward, awkward, awkward.
其他人:不想说话
Others: I don't want to talk.
其他人:一句都说不出来
Others: Can't say a word.
Tasha: 要开始了是吗
Tasha: Is it starting now?
Tasha: 这这就要开始了是吗
其他人:不然呢
Others: What else?
其他人:要不让他先说
Others: Should we let him start first?
其他人:你怕我怕我怕我怕
Others: You afraid, I'm afraid, we're all afraid.
其他人:不好吃
Other people: It doesn't taste good.
其他人:我很会做饭
Other people: I'm really good at cooking.
Tasha: 你很会做饭好
Tasha: You're really good at cooking, huh?
其他人:那个相机开了
Other people: That camera is on.
Jake:开了闪了
Jake: It's on and flashing.
Jake:就是开了
Jake: Yeah, it's on.
Jake:他他他我也不懂为什么
Jake: I don't really understand why.
Jake:反正他是开了
Jake: Anyway, it's on.
Jake:每个相机都有自己的个性
Jake: Every camera has its own personality.
其他人: 这不是check一个吗
Other people: Didn't we check it?
Jake:对是
Jake: Yes, we did.
Jake:我们主要check他
Jake: We're mainly checking it.
Jake:充电宝上面的灯和字是不是亮的
Jake: Is the light and display on the power bank on?
Jake:关了就这是和面用的
Jake: If it's off, it's for kneading dough.
Jake:这不行这不行
Jake: This won't work, this won't work.
Tasha: 都可以啊怎么用都可以
Tasha: It's fine, you can use it however.
Lucia:我去拿件外套
Lucia: I'll go get a jacket.
Tasha: 鸡蛋呢
Tasha: Where are the eggs?
Lucia:这样我就可以把它揣口袋里
Lucia: So I can put it in my pocket.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
其他人:有可能是打
Other people: It could be a hit.
其他人:但是你别先打
Other people: But don't hit first.
其他人:你要你要打他一会就就该教育你了
Other people: If you hit him, he'll educate you later.
其他人:我就不会
Other people: I wouldn't do it.
Jake:他不理你
Jake: He'll ignore you.
其他人:他竟然没说呢
Other people: He didn't say anything.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
其他人:在推测哈哈
Other people: Just guessing, haha.
Jake:他不理你怎么办
Jake: What if he ignores you?
其他人:他不理我就打
Other people: If he ignores me, I'll hit him.
Jake:好的哈哈
Jake: Okay, haha.
Alice:今天晚上做提拉米苏吗
Alice: Are we making tiramisu tonight?
Tasha: 是的呢哈哈哈
Tasha: Yes, haha.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Jake:确实哈哈哈
Jake: Indeed, haha.
Tasha: 什么
Tasha: What?
Jake:打打了一个熟蛋
Jake: Cracked a boiled egg.
Jake:哈哈哈啊
Jake: Hahaha.
Tasha: 啊那个是熟的
Tasha: Oh, it was boiled?
Jake:对打不出蛋黄哈哈
Jake: Yeah, you can't get the yolk out, haha.
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Tasha: 哎
Tasha: Hey
Alice:要用蛋清
Alice: You need to use egg whites
其他人:要什么我还没加呢
Others: What do you need? I haven't added anything yet
其他人:哈哈哈你怎么可能带着咳嗽
Others: Hahaha, how could you bring that with a cough?
其他人:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Others: Hahahahahahahahahahaha
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha
其他人:打那个碗里
Others: Crack it into that bowl
Tasha: 那个打蛋盆呢
Tasha: Where's the mixing bowl?
Jake:打蛋盆
Jake: Mixing bowl
其他人:先把鸡蛋加进去
Others: First, add the eggs
Tasha: 打蛋盆呢
Tasha: Where's the mixing bowl?
Jake:什么盆
Jake: Which bowl?
其他人:你有那个发泡的那个东西吗
Others: Do you have that whisk thing?
Jake:有他都有
Jake: Yeah, he has it all
其他人:洗一下吧你拿一下我洗
Others: Wash it, you get it and I'll wash it
Jake:那确实
Jake: That's true
Jake:易烊千玺哎
Jake: Jackson Yee, hey
Jake:我们好像是什么时候看到的
Jake: When did we see him?
Jake:那个王源
Jake: That Roy Wang
Jake:还是哦
Jake: Or oh
其他人:是那个去去去
Others: It was that time...
其他人:买瑞幸coffee的哦
Others: When we bought Luckin Coffee
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh
Tasha: 手也擦干吧
Tasha: Wipe your hands dry too
其他人:买芙蓉王时能看到王源
Others: When we bought Furong Wang cigarettes, we saw Roy Wang
其他人：已经干了
Others: It's already dry
其他人:芙蓉王源
Others: Furong Wang cigarettes, Roy Wang
其他人:尼古丁真
Others: Nicotine, really
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Tasha: 有何指示
Tasha: Any instructions?
其他人:坏了我们顺序要少于顺序
Others: Oh no, we're out of order
其他人：这你昨天用了吗
Others: Did you use this yesterday?
其他人:TF不好意思
Others: TF, sorry
Jake:哈哈完了完了
Jake: Haha, it's over, it's over
Tasha: 用了呀
Tasha: Yes, I used it
其他人：一股油味
Others: It smells like oil
其他人:我北半球我能收获一大批
Others: I can harvest a lot in the northern hemisphere
Tasha: 用了
Tasha: Used it
Tasha: 有淡奶油的味道
Tasha: It smells like cream
Tasha: 没擦干
Tasha: It's not dry.
Tasha: 这个要保持绝对的干
Tasha: This needs to be absolutely dry.
其他人:欧欧奥来讲还是赚哈哈哈
Others: Oh, oh, oh, still making money, hahaha.
Tasha: 行外面
Tasha: Okay, outside.
其他人: 这打蛋器你要不来打
Others: Do you want to use this mixer?
Tasha: 你要不来打
Tasha: Do you want to use it?
其他人:只加蛋清
Others: Just add egg whites.
Jake:来他会打
Jake: Come on, he can do it.
Jake:他来打打到打到
Jake: He'll mix it, mix it.
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Okay.
Tasha: 打到打到这里面
Tasha: Mix it, mix it in here.
其他人:打几个
Others: How many should we mix?
Jake:他可会打了
Jake: He's really good at this.
Jake:只加蛋清
Jake: Just add egg whites.
其他人:只加蛋清
Others: Just add egg whites.
Tasha: 不用你打进去就行了
Tasha: No need, just mix it in there.
Jake:他用手可以打蛋黄
Jake: He can use his hands to separate the yolk.
Jake:蛋黄弄出来
Jake: Separate the yolk.
Jake:可以
Jake: Okay.
其他人:这么高级可以
Others: So advanced, okay.
其他人:蛋壳不要了
Others: Discard the eggshell.
Tasha: 蛋壳不要了
Tasha: Discard the eggshell.
Jake:我来打个蛋
Jake: I'll crack an egg.
Jake:哈哈哎
Jake: Haha, hey.
其他人::我来打个
Others: I'll crack one.
Tasha: 哎等等等等
Tasha: Hey, wait, wait, wait.
Tasha: 我怕打坏了
Tasha: I'm afraid I'll mess it up.
Lucia:要要一个蛋就倒一次
Lucia: Just one egg at a time.
Tasha: 不然的话后果很严重
Tasha: Otherwise, the consequences will be serious.
其他人:又怕我打坏了
Others: Afraid I'll mess it up again.
Lucia:否则的话就很有浪费的风险很严重
Lucia: Otherwise, there's a risk of wasting a lot, very serious.
Tasha: OK第二位学徒上场
Tasha: Okay, second apprentice, your turn.
其他人:这要分开是吗
Others: Do we need to separate this?
Tasha: 不用你直接到就行了
Tasha: No need, just pour it directly.
其他人:卧槽她非要展示一下
Others: Damn, she insists on showing off.
Jake:这是手法
Jake: This is technique.
Lucia:哇哇
Lucia: Wow, wow.
Alice:你别把蛋黄弄破了
Alice: Don't break the yolk.
其他人:他必须要展示一下
Others: He has to show off a bit.
Tasha: 你把蛋黄弄破了你就死定了
Tasha: If you break the yolk, you're done for.
Jake:活着还活着
Jake: Still alive, still alive.
其他人:我靠牛啊
Others: Whoa, impressive.
Tasha: 哎哈哈哈哈受不了
Tasha: Oh, haha, I can't take it.
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahaha.
Jake:傻逼啊哈哈哈
Jake: Fool, hahaha.
Lucia:膨胀了膨胀了
Lucia: It's getting too big.
Jake:你这有变化吗
Jake: Is there any change?
Jake:你这来回倒这蛋黄到这哎
Jake: You keep moving this egg yolk around.
Tasha: 这蛋黄
Tasha: This egg yolk.
Tasha: 到这哎
Tasha: Over here.
Tasha: 干嘛
Tasha: What are you doing?
Tasha: 蛋清蛋清到底
Tasha: Egg white, egg white all the way.
其他人: 这个必须要这个完整
Others: This has to be whole.
Tasha: 嗯好
Tasha: Mm, okay.
Tasha: 下一个下一个
Tasha: Next one, next one.
Tasha: 谁要打
Tasha: Who wants to hit?
Jake:来来来来来来
Jake: Come on, come on, come on.
Lucia:我不敢打
Lucia: I'm afraid to hit.
其他人:来来来我不敢打
Others: Come on, come on, I'm afraid to hit.
Alice:我已经不敢打了
Alice: I don't dare to hit anymore.
其他人:我只能打打
Others: I can only hit a bit.
其他人:打进去就不错了
Others: It's good if it goes in.
其他人:你别把蛋黄打碎
Others: Don't break the yolk.
其他人:切都没有问题
Others: No problem cutting it.
其他人：我发现大家都是高手
Others: I realize everyone is an expert.
Lucia:哇哦我
Lucia: Wow, I...
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Alice:完整
Alice: Whole.
其他人:各显神通
Others: Everyone shows their skills.
Tasha: ok下一位
Tasha: Ok, next one.
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Lucia:哈哈哈哦
Lucia: Haha oh.
其他人：到你了
Others: It's your turn.
Jake:完完球
Jake: Done, done.
其他人：坏了我感觉
Others: Oh no, I feel like...
Lucia:哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Jake:哎可以可以
Jake: Ah, it's okay.
其他人：董莎莎来吧
Others: Jack, come on.
Jake:董莎莎来
Jake: Jack, come on.
其他人:我有些紧张
Others: I'm a bit nervous.
Jake:没关系没关系没关系
Jake: It's okay, it's okay, it's okay.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Lucia:你来你来
Lucia: You do it, you do it.
Jake:可以可以
Jake: Sure, sure.
Jake:一定成功
Jake: It will definitely work.
Tasha: 等等等
Tasha: Wait, wait, wait.
Alice:有有有在这呢
Alice: Got it, got it, it's here.
Tasha: 有有有
Tasha: Got it, got it, got it.
Jake:有的有的有的有的
Jake: Got it, got it, got it, got it.
Jake:可以成功
Jake: It will work.
Alice:给给你玩会
Alice: Here, you play with it for a while.
其他人:我只会最基础的
Others: I only know the basics.
Lucia:five goals
Lucia: Five goals.
其他人:因为因为当我需要打鸡蛋的时候
Others: Because, because when I need to crack eggs...
其他人:只会用来炒鸡蛋
Others: I only use it to make scrambled eggs.
Alice:那个转子啊在这
Alice: The rotor is here.
其他人:不会用来干别的
Others: I can't use it for anything else.
其他人:哦这是这个是吧
Others: Oh, this is it, right?
Jake:哎呦
Jake: Oh my!
Alice:对对对
Alice: Yes, yes, yes.
其他人:哎呦我操那个没事
Others: Oh my god, it's okay.
Lucia:那必须已经非常熟练了
Lucia: You must be very skilled by now.
Alice:玩吧
Alice: Go ahead and play.
Jake:可以出师了
Jake: You can graduate now.
其他人:他干嘛去
Others: Where is he going?
其他人:我好高级
Others: I feel so advanced.
其他人:感觉非常厉害
Others: I feel really awesome.
其他人:卧槽我要学一下打五个蛋
其他人:五个蛋试一下
Others: Try cracking five eggs.
Jake:开始偷了
Jake: Starting to cheat now.
Jake:哈哈哈你直接背就好了
Jake: Haha, just memorize it directly.
Tasha: 50克清水
Tasha: 50 grams of water.
Jake:围观
Jake: Watch.
其他人:哎那个蛋
Others: Hey, the egg...
其他人:卧槽我之前你这个打蛋打蛋器打多长时间
Others: Damn, how long did you use this egg beater?
其他人:20分钟吗
Others: 20 minutes?
Alice:20分钟都打服了
Alice: 20 minutes and it's all beaten.
Tasha: 什么东西
Tasha: What?
Tasha: 最高5分钟都打到
Tasha: At most, it takes 5 minutes.
Tasha: 不能再打了
Tasha: Can't beat it anymore.
其他人:我在我家
Other: I'm at home
其他人:我自己打篮球怎么打都打不起来
Other: I can't play basketball by myself
其他人:你自己还打嗯
Other: You still play by yourself, huh?
其他人:加加加多少
Other: How much should I add?
其他人:这个怎么锁
Other: How do you lock this?
其他人:你把你的配料贡献出来
Other: Share your ingredients
其他人:就他有在这吗
Other: Is he here?
Lucia:他有一个花你那按进去
Lucia: He has a flower, press it in there
Tasha: 在这呢吗
Tasha: Is it here?
Tasha: 往那里面加多少
Tasha: How much should I add in there?
Lucia:对顺着他就就按一下就可以了
Lucia: Yes, just press it down, and it will be fine
其他人:哦看到了然后呢
Other: Oh, I see it, then what?
Alice:按比例
Alice: According to the ratio
Lucia:哦不用就这样
Lucia: Oh no, just like that
Lucia:对按进去只要他不掉就他就按上了
Lucia: Yes, press it in, as long as it doesn't fall, it's fine
Tasha: 秤呢
Tasha: Where's the scale?
其他人:这么高级
Other: So fancy
Lucia:对就已经好了
Lucia: Yes, it's done
Tasha: 大家都看着我
Tasha: Everyone's looking at me
Tasha: 我有点紧张了
Tasha: I'm getting nervous
Jake:这是一代宗师和门下弟子
Jake: This is a master and his disciples
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Lucia:哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Tasha: 哈哈哈我想要矿泉水
Tasha: Hahaha, I want mineral water
Tasha: 清水水
Tasha: Clear water
Jake:师傅想喝水
Jake: The master wants water
Lucia:哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Tasha: 不是我想喝水这要水
Tasha: No, I want water, this needs water
Jake:矿泉水
Jake: Mineral water
Lucia:我们有
Lucia: We have it
Lucia:这个也行吧
Lucia: This will work too
Lucia:这是纯净水吗
Lucia: Is this purified water?
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah
Lucia:啊那行
Lucia: Ah, that's fine
Lucia:我记得刚刚应该有几个杯子
Lucia: I remember there should be some cups
Lucia:是我洗过的
Lucia: I washed them
Lucia:是这个吗
Lucia: Is it this one?
Lucia:管他呢冲一下哈哈
Lucia: Whatever, rinse it out haha
Tasha: 哎干什么
Tasha: Hey, what are you doing?
其他人：我知识试一下
Other: I'm just testing it
Jake:比划比划
Jake: Give it a try.
Jake:电都没插
Jake: It's not even plugged in.
Tasha: 等会给你用
Tasha: I'll let you use it later.
其他人：好
Others: Okay.
其他人:那个打蛋的呢
Others: Where's the egg beater?
其他人:那个去哪里了
Others: Where did it go?
其他人:多了
Others: Too much.
Tasha: 多了0.9克
Tasha: It's 0.9 grams too much.
其他人:有关系吗师傅
Others: Does it matter, Master?
Jake:喝掉喝掉
Jake: Drink it up.
Jake:哈哈哈够吗
Jake: Hahaha, is that enough?
Lucia:够吗
Lucia: Is that enough?
Tasha: 够了
Tasha: It's enough.
其他人:多少水啊
Others: How much water?
其他人：你不去皮吗
Others: Aren't you peeling it?
其他人:清水加50110
Others: Add 50110 of water.
其他人:然后100
Others: Then 100.
其他人:多多加了一克
Others: Added one gram more.
Alice:无妨
Alice: No problem.
Tasha: 您来搅
Tasha: You stir it.
其他人：用这个搅吧
Others: Use this to stir.
Tasha: 不用
Tasha: No need.
Tasha: 不要哈哈
Tasha: No, don't haha.
Lucia:那个这么小的碗会打飞出去吗
Lucia: Will it fly out of such a small bowl?
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
其他人:搅到什么程度
Others: To what extent do we stir?
Tasha: 找到他们俩完全融合
Tasha: Until they're fully combined.
Jake:水和油还能
Jake: Water and oil can...
Lucia:算了我拿着吧
Lucia: Never mind, I'll hold it.
其他人:水和油还能融合吗
Others: Can water and oil really combine?
Lucia:好没地放
Lucia: There's no place to put it.
Jake:就是可以融合
Jake: Yes, they can combine.
Jake:师傅说可以融合
Jake: Master says they can combine.
Shure: 这不没法
Shure: This can't be right.
Jake:牛顿算什么
Jake: What's Newton got on us?
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahahaha.
Tasha: 哈
Tasha: Haha.
其他人：听师傅的
Others: Listen to the master.
Shure: 给牛顿刨出来给师傅不是
Shure: Dig up Newton and let the master show him.
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahahahahahaha
其他人:给师傅埋进去
Others: Bury the master in it
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈可以可以可以如何
Jake: Hahahaha, okay, okay, okay, how about it?
其他人：高级高级
Others: Advanced, advanced
Tasha: 找到完全融合
Tasha: Found complete fusion
其他人:你觉得融合了吗
Others: Do you think it's fused?
Tasha: 我觉得没有
Tasha: I don't think so
Shure: 他俩这辈子也不能融合
Shure: They can't fuse in this lifetime
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahaha
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Jake:怕他变成金子
Jake: Afraid he'll turn into gold
Shure: 我从小接受的知识不允许我干这种行为
Shure: The knowledge I learned since childhood won't allow me to do this
Jake:这种金有水混合物
Jake: This kind of gold-water mixture
其他人:油水混合物
Others: Oil-water mixture
Lucia:哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
其他人:但是变成特别小
Others: But it becomes very small
其他人:的那种对
Others: That kind, yes
其他人:这个时候你给他加一点那个洗衣剂
Others: At this time, you add a little bit of detergent
其他人:也就是乳化
Others: It's emulsification
Lucia:哈哈别把还能吃吗
Lucia: Haha, can we still eat it?
其他人:哈哈哈
Others: Hahaha
Tasha: 再搅一搅
Tasha: Stir it again
Tasha: 我帮你倒下一个东西
Tasha: I'll help you pour the next thing
其他人:怎么感觉搅成面糊的感觉
Others: Why does it feel like it's turning into batter?
其他人:那个大的都去哪了
Others: Where did the big ones go?
Lucia:什么这个吗
Lucia: What, this one?
其他人:搅蛋清的啊
Others: The one for whipping egg whites
Lucia:在这啊哦
Lucia: It's here, oh
Jake:装蛋清哦
Jake: To hold egg whites, oh
Lucia:那个在冰箱里
Lucia: That one is in the fridge
Tasha: 完了完了
Tasha: It's over, it's over
其他人:还要冰一会是吧
Others: It needs to chill for a while, right?
Lucia:对对对
Lucia: Yes, yes, yes
Lucia:他是我们接下来会用到的妙妙小工具
Lucia: It's the magic little tool we'll use next
Jake:哈哈哈妙妙妙妙小冰壶
Jake: Hahaha, magic, magic, magic little ice rink
其他人:你这口开的有点
Others: Your opening is a bit...
Lucia:哈哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahahaha
Tasha: 多少克
Tasha: How many grams?
其他人:你先去皮
Others: You peel it first
Tasha: 去了放放
Tasha: Just let it sit.
其他人:你这你这
Others: What are you doing? What are you doing?
Tasha: 没关系我知道了
Tasha: It's okay, I got it.
其他人:40.8叫加50
Others: 40.8, add 50.
其他人:多一点多一点
Others: A bit more, a bit more.
其他人:卧槽精益求精
Others: Wow, perfecting it!
其他人:没事多一点多一点多一点
Others: It's okay, a bit more, a bit more, a bit more.
其他人:多吃一口
Others: Eat a bit more.
Jake:多吃1/500
Jake: Eat 1/500 more.
Tasha: 就这么多好
Tasha: That's enough.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Tasha: 继续搅
Tasha: Keep stirring.
其他人:我靠可以拿那个打蛋器吗
Others: Can I use that whisk?
Jake:哈哈喜欢打碗的
Jake: Haha, you like to use the bowl.
Tasha: 不可以
Tasha: No, you can't.
Alice:不可以
Alice: No, you can't.
其他人:这个可以
Others: This one works.
Tasha: 那个太大了
Tasha: That one's too big.
其他人:这正经面糊这味
Others: This is the real batter smell.
Alice:算盘我来吧不是
Alice: Let me do it, not...
其他人:纸杯蛋糕吗
Others: Cupcakes?
Tasha: 不是的
Tasha: No, it's not.
Lucia:纸杯蛋糕的纸杯
Lucia: Cupcake liners.
Jake:这写着呢
Jake: It's written here.
其他人:肉松小贝
Others: Pork floss cake.
其他人:这是什么东西
Others: What is this?
Tasha: 搅了吗
Tasha: Did you stir it?
Lucia:玉米淀粉
Lucia: Cornstarch.
其他人:搅了
Others: Stirred.
Jake:不带劲啊
Jake: Not exciting enough.
其他人:来看着很有食欲
Others: Looks appetizing.
其他人:我来上脸
Others: I'll put it on my face.
Jake:上点强度你这几档的
Jake: Add some intensity, which setting is this?
Jake:2档的这5档的
Jake: This is 2, this is 5.
其他人：要搅到多少
Others: How much more to stir?
其他人:还要加
Others: Still need to add more.
其他人:哎呦我操
Others: Oh my god.
Tasha: 倒到这个里面来吧
Tasha: Pour it into this.
Jake:哦现在你可以用你的机器了哦
Jake: Oh, now you can use your machine.
Tasha: 可以用那个蛋抽了
Tasha: You can use the whisk now.
Tasha: 呃那个那个蛋抽不是机器
Tasha: Uh, that whisk is not a machine.
Jake:机器
Jake: Machine?
Jake:蛋抽哦
Jake: Oh, the whisk.
Jake:还没到机器
Jake: It's not a machine yet.
Tasha: 对
Tasha: Right.
Tasha: 好嘞
Tasha: Got it.
其他人:这个碗底不要了吗
Others: Are we not using this bowl bottom?
Tasha: 不用了
Tasha: No, we're not.
其他人:所以说你刚刚进一球就没系列了
Others: So, after you scored, there's no series?
其他人:是为了让他配比是不是
Others: Is it to let him adjust the ratio?
Alice:配比是对的
Alice: The ratio is correct.
其他人:那个得洗一下
Others: That needs to be washed.
Tasha: 洗了之后用那个厨房纸巾擦一擦
Tasha: After washing, wipe it with a kitchen towel.
Tasha: 要干燥哦
Tasha: It needs to be dry.
Jake:他没开
Jake: It's not on.
其他人：然后直接打就行吗
Others: Then just beat it directly?
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Yeah.
其他人:配料什么的啥时候加
Others: When do we add the ingredients?
Tasha: 什么配料
Tasha: What ingredients?
其他人:就是糖什么的
Others: Like sugar and stuff.
Alice:我们的快递到了吗
Alice: Has our package arrived?
Tasha: 糖
Tasha: Sugar.
其他人:不是还有15克的糖吗
Others: Isn't there 15 grams of sugar?
其他人:忘了
Others: Forgot.
Tasha: 那就现在加吧哈哈哈
Tasha: Then add it now, hahaha.
Jake:好的哈哈哈
Jake: Okay, hahaha.
其他人:师傅是忘了
Others: The master forgot.
其他人:师傅失误了
Others: The master made a mistake.
Jake:没有菜单不对
Jake: No, the menu is wrong.
其他人:OKOK
Others: OK, OK.
其他人:可以少加点糖吗
Others: Can we add less sugar?
Jake:对应该菜单回去修改一下
Jake: Yeah, we should go back and modify the menu.
Tasha: 看他回去修改一下
Tasha: See, he'll go back and modify it.
其他人:应该什么时候加糖
Others: When should we add the sugar?
其他人:都行吧无所谓
Others: Anytime, it doesn't matter.
Jake:就现在就现在就现在就现在
Jake: Right now, right now, right now, right now.
Tasha: 就现在
Tasha: Right now.
Jake:这没差别吧
Jake: Doesn't make a difference, right?
Jake:这应该没差别
Jake: It shouldn't make a difference.
Jake:还没有发生什么化学变化
Jake: No chemical changes have happened yet.
其他人：师傅你怎么了
Others: Master, what's wrong?
Shure: 说我什么坏话了
Shure: Were you talking bad about me?
Shure: 又啊
Shure: Again, huh?
Shure: （歌词）他要到西天拜佛取真经
Shure: (Lyrics) He is going to the West to worship Buddha and seek true scriptures.
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
其他人:其实底料都是一样的
Others: Actually, the base ingredients are all the same.
Shure: 咱们晚饭吃什么呀老板
Shure: What are we having for dinner, boss?
Lucia:他真的好了解哈哈哈
Lucia: He really knows well, haha.
Jake:哈哈确实
Jake: Haha, indeed.
其他人:你调那个面包坯子都是一样的
Others: You make the dough the same way.
Shure: 咱们晚饭吃什么呀
Shure: What are we having for dinner?
Lucia:麦当劳麦当劳
Lucia: McDonald's, McDonald's.
Shure: 老板
Shure: Boss?
Jake:麦当劳麦当劳汉堡
Jake: McDonald's, McDonald's burger.
Tasha: 麦当劳汉堡
Tasha: McDonald's burger.
Shure: 那什什么时候点一下呀
Shure: When are we ordering?
Jake:啊现在是啊
Jake: Oh, right now.
Tasha: 慢慢慢蛋清
Tasha: Slowly, slowly, egg whites.
Lucia:啊现在拿下来是吧
Lucia: Oh, take it down now, right?
Tasha: 对
Tasha: Yes.
Lucia:对嗯我看我看
Lucia: Yes, let me see.
Jake:哈哈哈我觉得他这
Jake: Hahaha, I think this...
Lucia:我觉得他这
Lucia: I think this...
Lucia:他这个已经达到那个打蛋器的五档了
Lucia: He has reached level five on the egg beater.
Jake:啊哈哈哈
Jake: Ah, hahaha.
Tasha: 麦麦麦当劳汉堡
Tasha: McDonald's burger.
Jake:麦当劳汉堡
Jake: McDonald's burger.
Jake:加点
Jake: Add some...
其他人：菠萝可以啊
Others: Pineapple works.
其他人：要不要加点
Others: Should we add some?
其他人：加个菠萝
Others: Add a pineapple.
其他人：师傅要不要加入菠萝
Others: Master, do you want to add pineapple?
其他人：菠萝肉松小杯前面加点茉莉花茶
Others: Pineapple, meat floss, small cup, and add some jasmine tea in front.
其他人：前面加点茉莉花茶
Others: Add some jasmine tea in front.
其他人：或者这个葡萄
Others: Or this grape.
其他人：茉莉花和肉松小杯
Others: Jasmine and meat floss small cup.
其他人：给他增加点甜味
Others: To add some sweetness.
其他人：给他增加点甜味的
Jake:师傅喜欢吃瓜子
Jake: Master likes sunflower seeds.
Jake:哈哈哈不是瓜
Jake: Hahaha, not melon.
其他人：加点瓜子皮
Others: Add some melon seed shells.
Jake:瓜子仁我觉得烤一烤可以
Jake: I think roasting the melon seeds would be good.
Tasha: 来来来你来打这个吧
Tasha: Come on, come on, you do this.
Jake:这面糊里面放点花生仁吧
Jake: Let's add some peanuts to the batter.
Tasha: 好了好了
Tasha: Alright, alright.
Jake:是吧合理吧
Jake: Right? Makes sense, right?
Lucia:我得再来个杯子
Lucia: I need another cup.
其他人：咱只能在在哪里打
Others: We can only beat it here.
Lucia:哎又没了
Lucia: Oh, it's gone again.
Lucia:我刚洗那些上哪去了
Lucia: Where did the ones I just washed go?
Tasha: 打吧
Tasha: Beat it.
Tasha: 不不不
Tasha: No, no, no.
Jake:麦当劳汉堡
Jake: McDonald's burger.
Tasha: 我还以为你真会
Tasha: I thought you really knew how.
Jake:哎搜不到麦当劳
Jake: Hey, can't find McDonald's.
Jake:为啥
Jake: Why?
Shure: 卧槽
Shure: Damn.
Shure: 这没有麦当劳
Shure: There's no McDonald's.
Tasha: 停停
Tasha: Stop, stop.
Shure: 不会吧
Shure: No way.
Shure: 你去那个麦当劳小程序里看一看
Shure: Check the McDonald's mini program.
Tasha: 开
Tasha: Open it.
其他人：我的稍微搅一下在
Others: Stir mine a bit.
Tasha: 不用
Tasha: No need.
Tasha: 第一次要打到他有
Tasha: The first time, beat it until it has...
Tasha: 嗯没继续打
Tasha: Yeah, keep beating it.
Shure: 卧槽真没有麦当劳
Shure: Damn, no McDonald's for real.
Jake:谁有麦当劳小程序
Jake: Who has the McDonald's mini program?
Tasha: 朋友大家好
Tasha: Hi everyone.
Jake:你有吗我有我有
Jake: Do you have it? I have it, I have it.
Shure: 我有
Shure: I have it.
Jake:来来来试试
Jake: Come on, come on, try it.
Tasha: 我要
Tasha: I want it.
Jake:试试
Jake: Try it.
Tasha: 麦当劳汉堡
Tasha: McDonald's burger.
Tasha: 麦麦麦当劳汉堡
Tasha: Mc, Mc, McDonald's burger.
Jake:因为没有
Jake: Because there's none.
Jake:美团上没有
Jake: There's none on Meituan.
Tasha: 嗯这样子
Tasha: Oh, like this.
Tasha: 有这种细密的小气泡
Tasha: It has these fine little bubbles.
Tasha: 可以加第二次糖
Tasha: You can add the sugar a second time.
其他人：然后呢加多了
Others: And then you added too much.
Tasha: 哎呀没事没关系
Tasha: Oh, it's okay, no worries.
Tasha: 麦麦麦当劳汉堡
Tasha: McDonald's burger.
其他人：好香啊这个
Others: This smells so good.
其他人：就奶油其实这这是奶油
Others: It's just cream, actually, this is cream.
其他人：这是奶油
Others: This is cream.
Tasha: 这不是奶油
Tasha: This is not cream.
其他人：就这能直接吃吗
Others: Can you eat this directly?
Tasha: 这不可以直接吃
Tasha: You can't eat this directly.
Tasha: 打到现在
Tasha: Beat it until now.
Tasha: 打到他提起来不会掉下来
Tasha: Beat it until it won't fall when lifted.
Tasha: 呃提起来有小弯钩就行
Tasha: Uh, it should form a small hook when lifted.
Tasha: 你没有呢
Tasha: You don't have that yet.
Tasha: 远远没有
Tasha: Not even close.
Jake:哎呦只能只能到店取餐呢
Jake: Oh no, you can only pick it up from the store.
Tasha: 再打一分钟
Tasha: Beat it for another minute.
Jake:啥意思啊
Jake: What do you mean?
Jake:找个跑腿嗯
Jake: Find someone to run errands, hmm.
Tasha: 哦
Tasha: Oh.
Jake:怎么搞
Jake: How to do this?
Tasha: 真的送不到吗
Tasha: Really can't deliver it?
Jake:师傅说要把它给提起来
Jake: The master said you have to lift it.
Jake:不行然后不行
Jake: No, it's not working.
其他人：然后不行
Tasha: 再打一会吧
Tasha: Beat it for a while longer.
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
Jake:香的哈哈哈
Jake: Smells good, haha.
其他人：这好像啊真的有点想这能尝一口吗
Others: This really looks good, can we taste it?
Tasha: 你尝吧
Tasha: Go ahead, taste it.
其他人：会怎么样呢
Others: What will happen?
Tasha: 不会怎么样的
Tasha: Nothing will happen.
Tasha: 都是吃的难道还能死吗
Tasha: It's all edible, it won't kill you.
其他人：奶盖是这么做的吗
Others: Is this how milk foam is made?
Tasha: 奶盖不是这么做的
Tasha: No, milk foam isn't made this way.
Tasha: 奶盖是奶油奶酪加淡奶油
Tasha: Milk foam is made with cream cheese and light cream.
其他人：奶油是这么做的吗
Others: Is this how cream is made?
Tasha: 奶油不是这
Tasha: Cream isn't made this way.
Tasha: 么做奶油在冰箱里呢
Tasha: Cream is in the fridge.
Jake:怎么点宝宝随心拼
Jake: How to order the Baby Choice Combo?
Jake:我来看看现在麦当劳都有点啥
Jake: Let me see what McDonald's has now.
Jake:铂金奶铁我靠
Jake: Platinum milk tea, wow!
Tasha: 好了可以不打了
Tasha: Alright, you can stop now.
Tasha: 等一下再加最后一个定型的东西就行
Tasha: Wait a second, just add the final setting ingredient.
Jake:麦当劳
Jake: McDonald's.
Jake:麦当劳还卖小酥肉啊
Jake: McDonald's sells crispy meat too?
其他人：啊麦当劳那么高级
Others: Wow, McDonald's is so fancy.
Jake:我靠是颠覆认知啊
Jake: Wow, this is mind-blowing.
其他人：然后放肉松啊
Others: And then add some meat floss.
其他人：这什么东西啊
Others: What is this?
其他人：喝了啥小苏打
Others: Did you drink some baking soda?
Tasha: 呃差不多吧
Tasha: Uh, something like that.
Jake:差不多大苏打呵呵
Jake: More like large baking soda, haha.
Tasha: 好了
Tasha: Done.
其他人：这是什么
Others: What is this?
Tasha: 好再充分搅拌一下就OK了
Tasha: Alright, mix it thoroughly and it's done.
Tasha: 打发到不能再变大
Tasha: Beat it until it can't get any bigger.
Tasha: 一直打一直打
Tasha: Keep beating, keep beating.
Tasha: 打到他不会再变大
Tasha: Beat it until it won't get any bigger.
其他人:他已经变大了
Others: It's already big.
Tasha: 你他有没有变大嘛
Tasha: Do you think it got bigger?
Tasha: 你说蛋清
Tasha: I mean the egg whites.
其他人:没感觉
Others: I don't feel it.
其他人:我感觉这个有点就是太凝固了
Others: I think it's a bit too solidified.
Tasha: 完了
Tasha: It's done.
Tasha: 麦当劳汉堡
Tasha: McDonald's burger.
Tasha: 麦麦麦当劳汉堡
Tasha: Mc-Mc-McDonald's burger.
Shure: 点不了吧
Shure: You can't order it, right?
Shure: 这是到店取餐
Shure: This is for pick-up only.
Tasha: 这两个加起来
Tasha: Combine these two.
Jake:那他他准备
Jake: Then, they get ready.
Tasha: 打发到不能再变大
Tasha: Beat it until it can't get any bigger.
Jake:师傅准备找个跑腿
Jake: The master prepares to find a delivery guy.
其他人：你你哦行
Others: You, you, okay.
Shure: 啊也行
Shure: Ah, sure.
其他人:离多远我们过去
Others: How far is it? We can go there.
Jake:2.4公里
Jake: 2.4 kilometers.
Tasha: 打发到你觉得不能再变大的位置
Tasha: Beat it until you think it can't get any bigger.
Tasha: 就OK了
Tasha: Then it's okay.
Tasha: 你跟我来撕一下这个纸
Tasha: Come with me to tear this paper.
Tasha: 这里有这个
Tasha: There's this here.
其他人：还要撕吗
Others: Do we still need to tear it?
Tasha: 不要了
Tasha: No, we don't.
其他人：所以你蛋黄喝蛋白分开加的意义是什么
Others: So what's the point of adding egg yolk and egg white separately?
Tasha: 呃
Tasha: Uh...
Tasha: 分开家的意义是
Tasha: The point of adding them separately is...
其他人：参着蛋黄没办法给他打匀了
Others: You can't mix it evenly with the yolk.
其他人：那你可以一块打啊
Others: Then you can just mix them together.
Tasha: 不可以
Tasha: No, you can't.
其他人：只有蛋白和蛋黄打出来这样
Others: Only with egg white and yolk, you get this result.
Jake:来点汉堡吧
Jake: Let's get some burgers.
Tasha: 着急
Tasha: So impatient.
Jake:缺一人呢够了
Jake: Missing one person, it's enough.
Jake:勾人呢
Jake: Where's the person?
Shure: 啊
Shure: Huh?
Jake:勾呢
Jake: Where's the person?
Shure: 勾是不是睡着了勾
Shure: Did he fall asleep?
Jake:来师傅坐
Jake: Come, sit down, master.
Tasha: 不对
Tasha: No, that's not right.
其他人：不对
Others: Not right.
Tasha: 不对劲
Tasha: Something's wrong.
Lucia:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahahaha!
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha!
Jake:我看你不对劲
Jake: I think something's wrong with you.
Jake:看你不对劲
Jake: Something's wrong with you.
其他人：太稀了是吗
Others: Is it too runny?
Tasha: 对
Tasha: Yes.
其他人：确实太稀了为什么这么希
Others: It really is too runny, why is it so runny?
其他人：水加多了
Others: Too much water was added.
Tasha: 没有不对
Tasha: No, that's not right.
Jake:那怎么办呢
Jake: So what do we do?
其他人:主要是你打的手法不对
Others: The main issue is your mixing technique.
其他人:到了
Others: It's done.
Tasha: 继续打吧
Tasha: Keep mixing.
Jake:啥意思啊
Jake: What do you mean?
Jake:打反了哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Mixing it backwards, hahaha!
其他人:这还能打反
Others: Can you even mix it backwards?
Jake:那还能怎么回事啊
Jake: How can that even happen?
Jake:师傅为啥呀
Jake: Why, master?
Lucia:多打一会吧
Lucia: Let's play a little longer.
Tasha: 不知道吧
Tasha: You don't know, right?
其他人：你是不是淀粉搁少了
Others: Did you put too little starch?
Jake:你知道Revere吗
Jake: Do you know Revere?
Jake:就是说不对你就不行
Jake: Like, if it's not right, it's not gonna work.
Tasha: 算了稀了加粉
Tasha: Never mind, add more starch.
Jake:哈哈哈no more
Jake: Hahaha, no more.
Tasha: 粉了加干了加加水
Tasha: Add starch if it's thin, add water if it's thick.
其他人：但是Revere没有这么好
Others: But Revere isn't that good.
其他人：Revere不会告诉你
Others: Revere won't tell you.
Jake:不会告诉你要加什么
Jake: Won't tell you what to add.
其他人：不行就投下一个不适合这个就
Others: If it doesn't work, just move on to the next one.
Jake:这个这个这个真会写
Jake: This, this, this is really well-written.
Tasha: 还有吗
Tasha: Is there more?
Jake:这我真会写
Jake: I can really write this.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Tasha: 我也要一个这个
Tasha: I want one of these too.
Jake:我觉得你这个更适合
Jake: I think this suits you better.
Jake:哈哈哈AC芭提比
Jake: Hahaha, AC Bartyby.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure: 好了好了好了
Shure: Alright, alright, alright.
Jake:他干嘛呢
Jake: What is he doing?
Shure: 他对在干活
Shure: He's working.
Jake:他干活呢
Jake: He's working.
Jake:好嘞我草你
Jake: Okay, I'm gonna...
qtr :我操逆天了
QTR: Holy crap, this is insane.
Jake:天啊QBZ
Jake: Oh my god, QBZ.
其他人:下了半天没收到我操
Others: Been downloading forever and got nothing, damn.
Jake:你们公共区域在哪啊
Jake: Where's your public area?
其他人:公共区域应该在台湾区那个什么Patro
Others: The public area should be in the Taiwan area, that Patro.
Jake:那你
Jake: Then you...
Jake:那你弄过来呗
Jake: Then you bring it over.
其他人:我已经忘了康大该怎么软硬我怎么来
Others: I've already forgotten how to adjust it for Kongda.
Lucia:为什么会好像没什么
Lucia: Why does it seem like there's nothing...
Lucia:变化呀他应该会怎么样
Lucia: No change? What should it be like?
Jake:就直接copy过去
Jake: Just copy it over.
其他人:应该会怎么样
Others: What should it be like?
其他人:应该会特别丑是吗
Others: Should it be particularly ugly?
Jake:直接copy一个软件啊remove
Jake: Just copy a software, remove it.
Lucia:理论上会越打越稠好像
Lucia: Theoretically, it should get thicker as you beat it.
Jake:你点了吗
Jake: Did you start it?
Shure: 我没点呢
Shure: I haven't started yet.
Jake:没点好嘞
Jake: Not started, okay.
其他人:确实好吃
Others: It really tastes good.
Tasha: 没关系我看他们用厨师机要打5分钟
Tasha: It's okay. I saw them using the mixer for 5 minutes.
Tasha: 这种手抽机的话可能要打个10分钟吧
Tasha: For this hand mixer, it might take about 10 minutes.
Jake:你坐着打吧
Jake: Sit and mix it.
Jake:要不抱着打吧
Jake: Or hold it while mixing.
Lucia:请
Lucia: Please.
Jake:好 10分钟之后见
Jake: Alright, see you in 10 minutes.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahaha.
Lucia:哈哈 7分钟最后见
Lucia: Haha, see you in 7 minutes.
Lucia:休息一下马上回来
Lucia: Take a break, be right back.
Lucia:好我们可以咔了哈哈
Lucia: Okay, we can cut now. Haha.
Tasha: 这个状态是很不对的
Tasha: This state isn't right.
其他人：那怎么办
Others: So what now?
Tasha: 如果实在不行
Tasha: If it really doesn't work,
Tasha: 那就加面粉吧
Tasha: Then add some flour.
其他人：你可以再加点
Others: You can add a bit more.
Alice:好我现在要开始去装修我的地方了
Alice: Okay, I'm going to start decorating my place now.
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah.
Tasha: 其他人：
Tasha: Others:
Tasha: 再看一看吧
Tasha: Let's see again.
其他人:水或者什么加太多
Others: Too much water or something.
Tasha: 水或者什么加太多
Tasha: Too much water or something.
Tasha: 什么都没加多呀
Tasha: Nothing was added too much though.
Alice:你也要来吗
Alice: Are you coming too?
其他人:不是每个都各多了一克吗
Others: Didn't each one have an extra gram?
Lucia:可以看一眼吗
Lucia: Can I take a look?
Alice:可以
Alice: Sure.
Tasha: 你再说每个多一克就会影响这么大
Tasha: You're saying an extra gram in each could make such a big difference?
其他人:你看现在是不是稍微稠一点了
Others: See, isn't it a bit thicker now?
Tasha: 啊再继续抽吧
Tasha: Ah, keep mixing.
其他人:咱们那个料是不是再
Others: Is our mixture...
Tasha: 好了不要指责配方
Tasha: Okay, stop blaming the recipe.
Tasha: 要要好好打
Tasha: We need to mix it well.
Shure:  传给谁
Shure: Pass it to whom?
Tasha: 把那个他把那个空气抽干应该就
Tasha: If we get the air out, it should be fine.
Shure: 这是谁的手机
Shure: Whose phone is this?
其他人:我先点个汉堡
Others: I'll order a burger first.
Alice:呀呀呀
Alice: Yay yay yay
Lucia:我看看快递到了多少
Lucia: Let me check how many packages have arrived.
Lucia:床裙
Lucia: Bed skirt.
其他人:怎么这么多2加2呢
Others: Why are there so many 2+2s?
Alice:哎呦我的天呐
Alice: Oh my gosh.
Tasha: 麦麦麦当劳汉堡
Tasha: McDonald's burger.
其他人:你点了吗
Others: Did you order?
其他人:没
Others: No.
Tasha: 麦当劳汉堡
Tasha: McDonald's burger.
Tasha: 麦麦麦当劳汉堡
Tasha: 怎么办呢
Tasha: What should we do?
Tasha: 好了吗
Tasha: Is it done?
其他人：嗯
Others: Yeah.
Alice:谁踢了我的狗
Alice: Who kicked my dog?
Katrina: 我以为放那个我那隐形眼镜盒里摸
Katrina: I thought I put it in my contact lens case.
Katrina: 只摸到一格
Katrina: But I only found one compartment.
Katrina: 我要点一个外卖
Katrina: I need to order takeout.
Tasha: 还有人没点吗
Tasha: Has anyone else not ordered?
Jake:我来你你
Jake: I'll do it for you.
Tasha: 你你哦
Tasha: You, you, okay.
Tasha: 呃
Tasha: Uh.
Jake:哈哈你是谁
Jake: Haha, who are you?
其他人：我我是谁
Others: Who am I?
Tasha: 我没转头
Tasha: I didn't turn my head.
其他人：ok
Others: Okay.
Tasha: 麦当劳汉堡
Tasha: McDonald's burger.
其他人：随心配在哪里
Others: Where's the mix-and-match deal?
其他人：随心配2+2在哪哦
Others: Where's the mix-and-match 2+2 deal?
Tasha: 多人吃
Tasha: Many people are eating.
其他人：好高级
Others: So fancy.
Tasha: 我也吃这个
Tasha: I'm eating this too.
Tasha: 就是这2加2了不要再往下翻了
Tasha: It's just this 2+2, don't scroll down anymore.
其他人：这已经不二加了
Others: This isn't even a 2+2 anymore.
Tasha: 对
Tasha: Right.
Tasha: 这是2哦
Tasha: This is a 2.
其他人：这样感觉不是很值
Others: It doesn't seem worth it.
Shure: 他说有一些是虚拟号
Shure: He said some are virtual numbers.
Jake:我靠什么东西
Jake: What the heck is this?
Jake:呃还行吧
Jake: Uh, it's okay.
Jake:问题不大
Jake: It's not a big deal.
其他人：不太对是吧
Others: Something's not right, is it?
其他人：是不是鸡蛋坏了
Others: Could the eggs be bad?
Tasha: 是不是鸡蛋坏了
Tasha: Could the eggs be bad?
其他人：是不是鸡蛋不对
Others: Could there be something wrong with the eggs?
Jake:味对吧
Jake: The flavor's right, isn't it?
其他人：味儿是对的
Others: The flavor is right.
其他人：挺香的
Others: Smells good.
Jake:对啊为什么这么香
Jake: Yeah, why does it smell so good?
Tasha: 没事儿再再搅一搅
Tasha: It's okay, just stir it a bit more.
Jake:那坏蛋不是这味
Jake: Bad eggs don't smell like this.
Tasha: 再搅一搅
Tasha: Stir it a bit more.
其他人：哎是不是因为你那
Others: Hey, could it be because you...
其他人：个就是冻的时间不够长
Others: didn't freeze it long enough?
其他人：就是蛋清
Others: Just the egg whites.
Tasha: 我感觉那样打出来是对的
Tasha: I think it should look like this when beaten.
其他人：哪样打出来是对的
Others: This is how it should look when beaten?
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Mm-hmm.
其他人：你以前做过这个
Others: Have you done this before?
Tasha: 没有哈哈
Tasha: No, haha.
其他人：那我觉得无所谓
Others: Then I guess it doesn't matter.
其他人：就你别一会得得稠到能给捏成一个团是吗
Others: Just make sure it doesn't get too thick to form a lump, right?
Tasha: 不用就能成型就行
Tasha: No, as long as it can hold its shape, it's fine.
其他人：还要装盒里
Others: It still has to go in the box.
Tasha: 对
Tasha: Yeah.
其他人：搁纸盒里然后再搁盘子里
Others: Put it in a paper box, then on a plate.
Tasha: 不直接搁
Tasha: No, just put it directly.
Tasha: 纸盒里就直接这样堆起来
Tasha: Stack it directly in the paper box.
其他人：那那这也太希了那加点面粉吧
Others: But this is too thin, let's add some flour.
Tasha: 是啊啊不行你先打
Tasha: Yeah, no, you mix it first.
其他人：我觉得这已经差不多这样
Others: I think it's almost there like this.
其他人：感觉不是很对
Others: Feels a bit off.
其他人：就是确实很稀
Others: It's really too thin.
其他人：稍微加一点就行
Others: Just add a little bit more.
其他人：后来咱买的可能不是高筋就是用低筋
Others: Maybe we bought low-gluten flour instead of high-gluten.
Tasha: 就是用低筋
Tasha: It's low-gluten.
Tasha: 好了打打看
Tasha: Okay, mix it and see.
其他人：你看现在就稍微兑一点然后再加点淀粉
Others: See, just add a little more and then some cornstarch.
Tasha: 玉米淀粉用可可塔塔粉代替了呀
Tasha: Use cocoa powder instead of cornstarch.
其他人：哇
Others: Wow.
其他人：一模一样
Others: Exactly the same.
Tasha: 太可怕了
Tasha: That's so scary.
Tasha: 那我们找个容器把它放进去开始烤吧
Tasha: Let's find a container and start baking it.
其他人：就直接烤稀的了是吧
Others: We're just going to bake it as is, right?
Tasha: 麦当劳汉堡
Tasha: McDonald's burger.
Tasha: 麦麦麦当劳汉堡
Tasha: Mc-Mc-McDonald's burger.
Jake:Sakira是一首歌是吧
Jake: Sakira is a song, right?
Shure: 啊不是就是龙舌兰
Shure: No, it's just tequila.
Jake:就是有一首歌
Jake: There's a song about it.
Tasha: 这个托呢
Tasha: Where's the tray?
Jake:你们点过
Jake: Have you ordered?
Shure: 都点过了吧谁没点
Shure: Everyone's ordered, right? Who hasn't?
Alice:啊我没点
Alice: Ah, I haven't.
Tasha: 这个的托呢
Tasha: Where's the tray for this?
Jake:托
Jake: The tray.
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah.
Tasha: 好了你不知道在哪
Tasha: Alright, you don't know where it is.
Jake:我确实不知道在哪
Jake: I really don't know where it is.
其他人:我怎么闻到了一股加热的味道
Others: Why do I smell something heating up?
Jake:烤箱预热预热中
Jake: The oven is preheating.
Tasha: 哇哇
Tasha: Wow, wow.
Alice:你点了吗没呢
Alice: Did you order or not?
Jake:这是鼻子干的事吧哈哈哈
Jake: It's just the dry nose, haha.
Lucia:哎我们现在吃的
Lucia: Hey, the one we're eating now.
其他人：它加热会有味
Others: It smells when it's heating.
Tasha: 没事没事没事找个托我们开始加热吧
Tasha: It's okay, it's okay. Let's find a tray and start heating it.
Jake:托找不到找不着
Jake: Can't find the tray.
Jake:托是在这里头吗
Jake: Is the tray in here?
Tasha: 那那怎么办呢
Tasha: Then what should we do?
Jake:是在这里头
Jake: It's in here.
Jake:哎呦我靠
Jake: Oh my god.
Tasha: 是在这里头吗
Tasha: Is it in here?
Jake:是是
Jake: Yes, it is.
Tasha: 搁哪呢
Tasha: Where is it?
Jake:不知道啊
Jake: I don't know.
Tasha: 你翻一翻呀
Tasha: Turn it over and check.
Tasha: 扒拉扒拉呀
Tasha: Look for it.
Tasha: 哇靠哈哈
Tasha: Wow, gosh, haha.
Jake:啊哈哈哈
Jake: Ah, hahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈还还好还好皮厚
Jake: Haha, it's okay, it's okay. The skin is thick.
Jake:我靠哈哈
Jake: Oh my gosh, haha.
Jake:我靠师傅直接一刀
Jake: Oh my, the master directly slashed.
Jake:哈哈哈师傅刀我靠
Jake: Hahaha, the master slashed, oh my.
Jake:直接戳我一刀
Jake: Directly stabbed me.
Jake:砍一刀
Jake: Slashed me.
Tasha: 怎么办没有
Tasha: What to do, there's nothing.
Jake:砍一刀还好还好皮厚
Jake: A slash, it's okay, I have thick skin.
Tasha: 没有
Tasha: There's nothing.
其他人:确实没有
Others: Indeed, there's nothing.
Tasha: 没有怎么办
Tasha: What do we do with nothing?
其他人:刀太炖了
Others: The knife is too blunt.
其他人:没有直接倒进去
Others: Just pour it directly.
Jake:哈哈哈没有直接倒进去
Jake: Hahaha, just pour it directly.
Tasha: 不行
Tasha: No way.
其他人:拿手固定呗
Others: Hold it with your hand.
Jake:那因为手也放在烤箱里了
Jake: But the hand will be in the oven too.
其他人:是这个味吗是
Others: Is this the right taste?
其他人:哎
Others: Hey.
其他人:为什么鸡蛋一打打打开了就这么香呢
Others: Why does the egg smell so good when cracked?
Tasha: 这不是鸡蛋的问题吧
Tasha: It's not the egg's problem, right?
Jake:找到了这算没有
Jake: Found it, does this count as nothing?
其他人:那是哪个香
Others: Then what smells good?
Tasha: 没有
Tasha: Nothing.
其他人:蛋糕粉香
Others: The cake mix smells good.
其他人:蛋糕哎
Others: Cake, hey.
其他人:蛋糕粉也不香
Others: The cake mix doesn't smell good.
Shure: 真的 吗
Shure: Really?
其他人:糖香
Others: The sugar smells good.
Tasha: 加了糖吧
Tasha: Added sugar, right?
Tasha: 糖和鸡蛋
Tasha: Sugar and egg.
其他人:谁研究的
Others: Who researched this?
其他人:谁研究的这玩意呢
Others: Who researched this thing?
Tasha: 从高处没过筛呢
Tasha: It wasn't sifted from a height.
Tasha: 搞什么呢
Tasha: What are you doing?
Tasha: 筛网
Tasha: Sieve.
Tasha: 洗过了
Tasha: Washed.
Shure: 啊好香啊
Shure: Ah, it smells so good.
其他人:师傅这个怎么样啊
Others: Master, how is this?
Shure: 我们是不是应该一会排练一下
Shure: Shouldn't we rehearse a bit later?
Tasha: 不是
Tasha: No.
Shure: 明天的歌曲来着
Shure: For tomorrow's song.
Tasha: 没事没事不垫油纸
Tasha: It's okay, it's okay, we don't need parchment paper.
Katrina: 哦忘了哈哈哈
Katrina: Oh, I forgot, hahaha.
Shure: 工人怎么变批人了
Shure: How did the workers become a batch of people?
Shure: 这两天
Shure: These past couple of days...
Katrina: 再待两天
Katrina: Stay for two more days.
Tasha: 完了多了
Tasha: Oh no, there's too much.
Katrina: 我完蛋了
Katrina: I'm doomed.
Jake:哈哈一个批房啊
Jake: Haha, a batch room!
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Tasha: 不多刚刚好
Tasha: It's not too much, it's just right.
Jake:啊这是一个批房啊
Jake: Ah, this is a batch room.
Jake:进来的人一定是批人
Jake: Everyone who comes in is a batch person.
Katrina: 嗯我要完蛋了
Katrina: Hmm, I'm really doomed.
Tasha: 可以可以了吧
Tasha: Is it okay now?
Alice:好了
Alice: It's ready.
Tasha: 就这样吧不知道烤出来什么东西
Tasha: Let's leave it like this, not sure what it will turn out like.
Jake:点完了都点完了
Jake: All done, everything is done.
Tasha: 好了
Tasha: Alright.
Jake:都点了
Jake: All done.
Lucia:我还没点
Lucia: I haven't done it yet.
Jake:哦好
Jake: Oh, okay.
Jake:你选哪一個
Jake: Which one do you choose?
Jake:加一看你选哪一个加1
Jake: Add one, let's see which one you choose, add one.
Tasha: 噔噔噔噔噔
Tasha: Dun dun dun dun dun.
其他人：这就可以了
Others: This is fine.
其他人：对
Others: Yes.
Jake:所以还是没找着是吧
Jake: So we still didn't find it, right?
Tasha: 没找着没关系
Tasha: It's okay if we didn't find it.
其他人：卧槽直接用手哦有手套
Others: Whoa, using hands directly? Oh, there's gloves.
Jake:哼这包还在这
Jake: Hmph, this bag is still here.
Jake:包还没变过呢
Jake: The bag hasn't changed.
Jake:开始魔法
Jake: Starting the magic.
Tasha: 知道那里出了问题
Tasha: I know where the problem is.
Jake:你猜是谁
Jake: Guess who it is.
Tasha: 好了洗洗我们下一个吧
Tasha: Alright, wash up, let's move on.
Jake:不是
Jake: No.
其他人:咱们往里面加点那个
Others: Let's add some of that inside.
Tasha: 那也得出来再加了
Tasha: We should add it after it comes out.
其他人:现在正好埋里边
Others: It's perfect to bury it inside now.
Tasha: 可以啊你想埋埋
Tasha: Sure, if you want to bury it, bury it.
Tasha: 真的吗
Tasha: Really?
Tasha: 不用戴手套的
Tasha: You don't need to wear gloves.
Tasha: 你这么爱吃菠萝吗
Tasha: Do you really love eating pineapple that much?
其他人:就是随便加点加点菠萝草莓
Others: Just add some pineapple and strawberries.
Jake:主要是看到的菠萝
Jake: Mainly because I saw the pineapple.
Jake:他说看到草莓应该也会加
Jake: He said if he saw strawberries, he'd add those too.
Tasha: 会好吃吗
Tasha: Will it taste good?
Jake:你不得切一切
Jake: Don't you need to cut it up?
Jake:哎好嘞
Jake: Oh, okay.
Tasha: 好嘞
Tasha: Alright.
其他人:但是我不知道他烤出来是不是我一样
Others: But I don't know if it will bake the same way.
其他人:用的烤菠萝
Others: Using grilled pineapple.
其他人:烤菠萝不都是在那个烤架上烤
Others: Isn't grilled pineapple usually cooked on the grill?
Jake:火烤啊
Jake: Over a fire.
其他人：你知道烤菠萝吗
Others: Do you know grilled pineapple?
Jake:上火
Jake: On a fire.
Tasha: 这在哪开啊
Tasha: Where do you open this?
Tasha: 拿12个
Tasha: Take 12.
Jake:哦这边有镊子
Jake: Oh, there are tweezers here.
Tasha: 把托找一下行吗
Tasha: Can you find the tray?
Jake:把什么
Jake: Find what?
Tasha: 托
Tasha: The tray.
Jake:对我在找托
Jake: Yeah, I'm looking for the tray.
其他人:那我就不客气了
Others: Well, then I won't be polite.
其他人:您是要做啥蛋挞
Others: What kind of egg tart are you making?
Tasha: 这个蛋挞很简单
Tasha: This egg tart is very simple.
Tasha: 来个简单的
Tasha: Let's make a simple one.
Tasha: 这个我做过好多遍
Tasha: I've made this many times.
Tasha: 提拉米苏也做过好多遍
Tasha: I've also made tiramisu many times.
Tasha: 这两个不会失败的
Tasha: These two won't fail.
其他人:提拉米苏你买那个可可粉了吗
Others: Did you buy the cocoa powder for tiramisu?
Tasha: 买了还买了一个专业的
Tasha: Yes, I bought a professional one too.
Jake:这蓝莓怎么这么丑啊
Jake: Why do these blueberries look so ugly?
其他人:哦可以可以
Others: Oh, it's okay, it's fine.
其他人:哦这样子的
Others: Oh, like this.
其他人:师傅你学会了吗
Others: Master, have you learned it?
Jake:哈哈哈什么呵呵
Jake: Hahaha, what?
Tasha: 什么
Tasha: What?
其他人:这样子好像
Others: Like this, I think.
Tasha: 呵我们
Tasha: Heh, we...
Jake:教师傅撕保鲜袋
Jake: Master Jie tore the cling film.
Tasha: 我我我好像学会了
Tasha: I think I’ve got it.
Tasha: 看你这样操作
Tasha: Watching you do it like this.
Jake:真的没有吗
Jake: Really, there's none?
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Alright then.
Tasha: 你还记得吗
Tasha: Do you still remember?
Tasha: 那天我们明明一起把那个托
Tasha: That day, we clearly put the tray...
Tasha: 盘削在这的结果就不见了
Tasha: ...and then it just disappeared.
其他人:真的打不开
Others: Really can't open it.
Jake:这不合理啊
Jake: This doesn't make sense.
Jake:我来打
Jake: Let me try.
Jake:你拿这个打
Jake: You use this to hit it.
其他人:打不开一点
Others: It won't open at all.
Jake:真的
Jake: Really.
其他人:牛逼
Others: Awesome.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia:有人要去取快递吗
Lucia: Anyone going to pick up the delivery?
Jake:啊他可以现在单独去取吗
Jake: Ah, can he go pick it up by himself now?
Lucia:他说他现在忙不过来
Lucia: He said he's too busy right now.
Jake:那
Jake: Then...
Lucia:您能帮忙取一下吗
Lucia: Can you help pick it up?
Jake:他说让自己取是吧
Jake: He said to pick it up himself, right?
Tasha: 你干嘛带上
Tasha: Why are you putting that on?
Jake:因为比较平
Jake: Because it's flat.
Jake:对是吧多好
Jake: Yeah, right? It’s so much better.
Tasha: 别倒
Tasha: Don’t spill it.
Jake:哎呀好冰啊
Jake: Oh, it's so cold.
Tasha: 一二三四五六七八九十
Tasha: One, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight, nine, ten.
Tasha: 1112 好
Tasha: Eleven, twelve. Done.
Tasha: 把它拆开就行
Tasha: Just open it up.
Jake:哎呀好冰好冰
Jake: Oh, so cold, so cold.
Jake:不行了不行了不行了不行了不行了
Jake: I can't, I can't, I can't. It’s too much.
Jake:冻坏了冻坏了
Jake: It's freezing.
Jake:哎哟我去
Jake: Oh my god.
Jake:就是蛋挞皮放我手上
Jake: Just put the tart shells on my hand.
Jake:你那手不是戴着手套吗
Jake: Aren't you wearing gloves?
Tasha: 在
Tasha: Yes.
Jake:蛋挞放在了外边
Jake: The tart is outside.
其他人：哦
Others: Oh.
Jake:找到了
Jake: Found it.
Tasha: 点什么还在点吗
Tasha: Are you still ordering?
Jake:不不不点了不点了
Jake: No, no, we're done ordering.
Tasha: 500多块钱怎么吃到500多的
Tasha: How did we spend over 500 bucks?
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
Jake:不知道
Jake: I have no idea.
Tasha: 我靠这个人谁
Tasha: Who the heck is this person?
Tasha: 太过分了
Tasha: This is too much.
Tasha: 吃一个77块钱的套餐
Tasha: Someone ordered a $77 meal.
Jake:谁呀
Jake: Who did that?
Tasha: 我只吃了那个22块钱的套餐
Tasha: I only had a $22 meal.
Jake:揪出来揪出来
Jake: Find out who did it.
Tasha: 揪出来我只吃了27块钱
Tasha: Yeah, find out. I only spent 27 bucks.
Tasha: 他吃七十几
Tasha: Someone spent over seventy.
Jake:没关系分掉
Jake: It's okay, we'll split it.
Jake:瓜分掉
Jake: We'll divide it up.
Jake:到时候大家盲选好吧
Jake: Everyone will blindly pick, alright?
Jake:我就在这拖着嘛
Jake: I'm just stalling here.
Tasha: 你把这个麦津会员开了是吗
Tasha: Did you activate the membership for this place?
Jake:我我我没动他
Jake: No, no, I didn't touch it.
Tasha: 因为他写他只要19块钱
Tasha: Because it says it's only 19 bucks.
Tasha: 但他这一单可以减37块5
Tasha: But you can save 37.5 on this bill.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake:那肯定买了
Jake: Then someone must have bought it.
Tasha: 我靠怎么会买到56068块钱
Tasha: How did we end up spending 56,068 bucks?
其他人:咱多少咱这么多人
Others: We have so many people.
Tasha: 那好吧
Tasha: Alright then.
Jake:咱总共9个
Jake: We have a total of 9 people.
Alice:是不是有的套餐那个啥
Alice: Maybe some meals are like that.
Jake:咱总共10个人
Jake: We have a total of 10 people.
Alice:超过一份就原价了还是怎么样
Alice: If you order more than one, is it full price?
Tasha: 太离谱了
Tasha: This is ridiculous.
Jake:9个人吗
Jake: Do we have 9 people?
Tasha: 我们是选这个餐厅吗
Tasha: Did we choose this restaurant?
Tasha: 哦好吧
Tasha: Oh, alright.
Tasha: 是选这个餐厅
Tasha: We chose this restaurant.
Jake:因为撤嗯
Jake: Because we cancelled, hmm.
Tasha: 我靠太离谱了
Tasha: This is just too much.
Jake:67899个哦
Jake: 67,899 of them, oh.
其他人：对你们车坐4个我们车坐4个
Others: Yeah, you guys take 4, we take 4.
Jake:这么回事哦
Jake: So that's how it is.
Jake:你们做的
Jake: You guys did it.
Jake:哦行吧
Jake: Oh, okay.
Jake:你们做的
Jake: You guys did it.
Tasha: 568块钱啊
Tasha: 568 yuan.
Jake:好 9个9个
Jake: Alright, nine of them.
Jake:点了500多
Jake: Ordered more than 500.
Jake:也行吧合理合理
Jake: Well, it's reasonable.
Katrina: 那个酒要现在点吗
Katrina: Should we order the wine now?
Jake:10刀嘛
Jake: 10 bucks each.
Jake:一人10刀嘛
Jake: 10 bucks each person.
Katrina: 风舌兰没买到
Katrina: They didn't have the windsor orchids.
Jake:嗯买到了哎
Jake: Hmm, they got it.
Jake:不是你点到了
Jake: Didn't you order it?
Jake:已经买完了
Jake: It's already bought.
Katrina: 啊那
Katrina: Ah, then...
Jake:外卖卖完了
Jake: Delivery is sold out.
Katrina: 爽
Katrina: Cool.
Tasha: 这烤箱还垃圾
Tasha: This oven is trash.
Jake:这还特地租的呢
Jake: We even specially rented it.
Katrina: 相当垃圾了
Katrina: It's really trash.
Tasha: 怎么垃圾了
Tasha: What's so bad about it?
其他人：这门这都不隔热就是塑料的
Others: The door doesn't insulate heat, it's just plastic.
Jake:小米
Jake: Xiaomi.
Tasha: 这小米的
Tasha: It's from Xiaomi.
Tasha: 这不隔热
Tasha: It doesn't insulate.
Tasha: 我觉得有手套还行吧
Tasha: I think it's okay with gloves though.
其他人：它大米他也不行
Others: Even for rice, it's no good.
其他人：这还挺香
Others: It smells good though.
Jake:哎呦我去
Jake: Oh my goodness.
Jake:可算
Jake: Finally.
Tasha: 买可贵了
Tasha: Bought it at a high price.
Jake:可算拿下去了
Jake: Finally got it down.
其他人：这个这个皮我感觉然后怎么 弄
Others: This, this skin, I feel like, how should we do it?
Tasha: 然后把洗一洗
Tasha: Then just wash it.
其他人：这可以接着用吗
Others: Can we still use it?
Tasha: 不可以接着用了
Tasha: No, we can't use it anymore.
其他人：为什么
Others: Why?
Jake:加薯片行吗
Jake: Can we add some chips?
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahahahahahahahahahahaha.
Tasha: 还是就用这些
Tasha: Or should we just use these?
Jake:蛋挞加薯片是不是也还行啊
Jake: Egg tarts with chips, not bad, right?
Tasha: 可以
Tasha: Yeah, sure.
Jake:我觉得挺好
Jake: I think it's pretty good.
Tasha: 谁把放在这
Tasha: Who put this here?
Jake:我走了
Jake: I'm leaving.
Jake:应该不是我应该不是我应该不是我
Jake: It shouldn't be me, it shouldn't be me, it shouldn't be me.
Jake:因为我没收拾
Jake: Because I didn't clean up.
Jake:哈哈哈应该不是我
Jake: Hahaha, it shouldn't be me.
Tasha: 的
Tasha: Yeah.
Jake:麦当劳汉堡我的
Jake: The McDonald's burger is mine.
Jake:切把切了哈
Jake: Cut it, just cut it.
其他人：擦一下
Others: Wipe it.
Tasha: 行我来我来我来擦
Tasha: Alright, I'll do it, I'll wipe it.
Jake:我再给我
Jake: I'll give you...
Jake:再给你们一个芒果的配料
Jake: another mango ingredient.
其他人：其实蛋挞里就可以随便加吧
Others: Actually, you can add anything to egg tarts.
Tasha: 蛋挞上面应该随便加8的蛋挞
Tasha: Yeah, you can add anything on top of egg tarts.
Tasha: 烤完蛋挞不会只有一人一个吧 12个
Tasha: After baking the egg tarts, won't there be only one per person? 12 of them.
其他人:蛋挞不会只有一人一个吧
Others: There won't be just one egg tart per person, right?
Tasha: 12个
Tasha: 12 of them.
其他人:还真一人
Others: It's really one per person.
其他人:差不多一个
Others: Almost one each.
Tasha: 一人吃一个还不够吗
Tasha: One each isn't enough?
其他人：我不够
Others: Not enough for me.
Tasha: 行那你吃两个番茄
Tasha: Alright, then you can have two tomatoes.
Tasha: 我要吃10个
Tasha: I want to eat 10.
Jake:呵呵呵
Jake: Hehehe.
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Okay.
Jake:剩下8个人分两个呵呵
Jake: The remaining 8 people will share 2, haha.
Tasha: 你真想吃的话咱们就烤24个
Tasha: If you really want, we can bake 24.
Jake:呵呵
Jake: Haha.
其他人：可以吗
Others: Can we?
其他人：有没有不甜的可不可以做个不甜的蛋挞
Others: Is there a way to make non-sweet ones? Can we make non-sweet egg tarts?
Tasha: 不可以做不甜的
Tasha: No, we can't make non-sweet ones.
Tasha: 你吃不甜的
Tasha: You eat non-sweet?
Tasha: 你吃什么甜品
Tasha: What kind of dessert is that?
其他人：我就想吃不甜的
Others: I just want to eat non-sweet ones.
Tasha: 你想吃不甜的
Tasha: You want non-sweet ones?
其他人：不加糖可以吗单独做四个不加糖的
Others: Is it okay to make four without sugar?
其他人：或者少加点糖
Others: Or just add less sugar.
Tasha: 那我们就做个低糖的吧
Tasha: Then let's make a low-sugar one.
其他人：不甜的甜品
Others: A dessert that's not sweet.
其他人：是中国人对甜品的最高评价
Others: That's the highest praise for a dessert from a Chinese person.
Jake:有很多可以代替剪刀的东西
Jake: There are many things that can replace scissors.
其他人：一般说这个东西不甜那就是对这个甜品评价很高
Others: When someone says it's not sweet, it means they think highly of it.
其他人：我说的对不对
Others: Am I right?
Tasha: 对的
Tasha: Yes, you are.
Tasha: 您说什么都对
Tasha: Whatever you say is right.
Jake:所以为什么呢
Jake: So why is that?
Jake:为什么不甜他就最高评价了
Jake: Why is it that not sweet is the highest praise?
Tasha: 就说明他不腻
Tasha: It means it's not too rich.
其他人:就说明这个甜品的额编不下去了
Others: It means this dessert... I can't go on.
其他人:很不甜比较健康
Others: It's not too sweet, so it's healthier.
Tasha: 很不甜比较健康
Tasha: It's not too sweet, so it's healthier.
其他人:比较健康
Others: It's healthier.
Tasha: 比较健康
Tasha: It's healthier.
Jake:那为什么不吃草
Jake: Then why not just eat grass?
其他人:就是不甜中
Others: It means not sweet...
其他人:你们能感感受到
Others: You can feel...
其他人:这个糖给你带来的愉悦
Others: The pleasure the sugar brings you.
Jake:哦哇
Jake: Oh wow.
其他人:上海人那么机器真好用
Others: Shanghai people, their machines work so well.
Jake:为什么呢
Jake: Why is that?
Jake:突然好用了
Jake: Suddenly it works.
其他人:一配就配通了
Others: Once you match it, it works.
Jake:你这配了
Jake: Did you match it?
Jake:你配多久
Jake: How long did you match it?
Tasha: 这都擦干了
Tasha: It's all wiped dry.
Tasha: 你就放进来你
Tasha: Just put it in.
Jake:好吧
Jake: Okay then.
其他人:问题不大不要着急
Others: It's not a big problem, don't worry.
其他人:现在可以了
Others: Now it's fine.
其他人：搁这了
Others: Put it here.
Tasha: 搁
Tasha: Put it.
其他人：这个也要擦
Others: This needs to be wiped too.
其他人：这个也要洗
Others: This needs to be washed too.
Tasha: 是的吗
Tasha: Really?
其他人：哎呀
Others: Oh no.
其他人： 就感觉带点油的东西确实不是很好洗
Others: It feels like things with oil are really hard to clean.
其他人：还可以少少搁点油
Others: You can add a little less oil.
其他人：怎么能烤糊
Others: How could it get burnt?
其他人：是吗
Others: Really?
其他人：是你烤糊过吗
Others: Have you ever burnt something?
Tasha: 谁没烤糊过东西
Tasha: Who hasn't burnt something?
其他人：这咋样
Others: How is it?
Tasha: 感觉
Tasha: Feels like...
Tasha: 应该没问题
Tasha: It should be fine.
Tasha: 我觉得烤出来东西都不会难吃
Tasha: I think anything baked won't taste bad.
其他人：确实毕竟没加什么难吃的东西
Others: True, after all, we didn't add anything that tastes bad.
其他人：你说擦干净是为啥
Others: Why do you say to clean it?
Tasha: 没加有的不加水啊
Tasha: Because we didn't add water.
其他人：那你刚才那个不是加水了吗
Others: But didn't you add water earlier?
Tasha: 是的呢
Tasha: Yes.
其他人：别坐别坐
Others: Don't sit down.
Tasha: 没做没做
Tasha: I'm not sitting.
其他人：这是炼乳
Others: This is condensed milk.
Tasha: 对哎呀
Tasha: Yes, oh my.
其他人：炼乳其实应该少吃
Others: You should eat less condensed milk.
Tasha: 是的还没开罐呢咱们
Tasha: Yeah, we haven't even opened it yet.
Tasha: 那你今天吃吗
Tasha: Are you going to eat it today?
其他人：不吃
Others: No.
Tasha: 好那你别吃蛋挞了
Tasha: Alright then, don't eat the egg tart.
其他人：啊蛋挞里也加炼乳了
Others: Huh, there's condensed milk in the egg tart?
Tasha: 是的
Tasha: Yes.
其他人：为什么要少吃
Others: Why eat less?
其他人：有反式脂肪
Others: It has trans fats.
其他人：炼乳直接蘸饼干蘸面包什么的
Others: Condensed milk is for dipping biscuits or bread.
Tasha: 麦当劳汉堡
Tasha: McDonald's burger.
其他人： 哪来的糖啊
Others: Where's the sugar from?
Tasha: 哪有糖啊
Tasha: Where is the sugar?
Tasha: 这底部的
Tasha: At the bottom.
其他人： 哦哦加吗
Others: Oh, should we add it?
Tasha: 哎等等
Tasha: Wait a sec.
其他人:麦当劳有跑腿吗
Others: Does McDonald's deliver?
Tasha: 还没点呢
Tasha: Haven't ordered yet.
Tasha: 哎呦我天呐
Tasha: Oh my gosh.
Tasha: 我好急啊
Tasha: I'm so anxious.
Tasha: 我好忙呀
Tasha: I'm so busy.
其他人:点了吗
Others: Have you ordered?
Tasha: 我看看我看看
Tasha: Let me check.
Tasha: 卖的带取餐了已经
Tasha: The order already includes the meal pickup.
Tasha: 好那就现在开始点跑腿
Tasha: Alright, let's start the errands now.
其他人：一会一会一会教我怎么size GPU啊
Others: Can you teach me how to size the GPU later?
其他人：嗯教我怎么size GPU
Others: Yeah, teach me how to size the GPU.
其他人：你那不是可以吗
Others: Can't you do it?
其他人：怎么怎么怎么切到
Others: How do you switch to...
其他人：就我现在管理系列
Others: I'm managing the series now.
其他人：好对你一会教教我就行
Others: Okay, just teach me later.
其他人：我就可以跑十年了哎
Others: Then I can run for ten years.
其他人：你之前没用slow那个那个对
Others: You haven't used the slow one before, right?
Tasha: 哪家店的
Tasha: Which store?
Tasha: 麦当劳呀
Tasha: McDonald's.
Tasha: 我的天呐
Tasha: Oh my gosh.
Tasha: 好烦好烦好烦好烦
Tasha: So annoying, so annoying, so annoying.
Tasha: 宁清宁清
Tasha: Ningqing, Ningqing.
Tasha: 然后加那个
Tasha: Then add that.
Tasha: 这是哪家店
Tasha: Which store is this?
Tasha: 哎旺仔牛奶呢
Tasha: Hey, where's the Wangzai milk?
Tasha: 哦这呢
Tasha: Oh, here it is.
Tasha: 旺仔牛奶
Tasha: Wangzai milk.
其他人：加旺仔牛奶
Others: Add Wangzai milk.
Tasha: 对
Tasha: Yes.
其他人：加多少
Others: How much to add?
Tasha: 加多少颗
Tasha: How many pieces?
Tasha: 旁边有写
Tasha: It's written on the side.
Tasha: 群芳中三阶
Tasha: Qunfang Middle Third Order.
其他人：这个你是当纯牛奶用的是吗
Others: Are you using this as pure milk?
Tasha: 对
Tasha: Yes.
其他人：这你当纯牛奶用那我觉得糖得少加很多了
Others: If you're using it as pure milk, I think you should add a lot less sugar.
其他人：115克
Others: 115 grams.
Tasha: 多少号呀多少号多少号多少号 35447235472
Tasha: What number, what number, what number, 35447235472.
Tasha: 手机要关机了完了
Tasha: My phone is about to shut down.
其他人：可以拿勺出来
Others: You can take out the spoon.
Tasha: 不用了就这样吧
Tasha: No need, let's just leave it like this.
其他人：不行精益求精
Others: No, we need to be precise.
Tasha: 我靠真受不了了
Tasha: I really can't take it anymore.
Tasha: 加旺仔牛奶更好吃
Tasha: Adding Wangzai milk makes it taste better.
其他人:那可以少搁点糖吗
Others: Then can we add less sugar?
Tasha: 少搁吧那你就少搁
Tasha: Add less then, just add less.
Lucia:害怕了
Lucia: I'm scared.
其他人:然后加炼乳了加到155
Others: Then add condensed milk up to 155.
Tasha: 加
Tasha: Add.
Tasha: 你就直接去皮不就行了吗
Tasha: Can't you just peel it directly?
其他人:嗯加40
Others: Yeah, add 40.
Tasha: 糖加过了吗
Tasha: Did you add the sugar?
其他人:没加
Others: No, not yet.
Tasha: 才加14颗糖而已
Tasha: We've only added 14 pieces of sugar.
Tasha: 平摊到每个人身上
Tasha: Spread it out for everyone.
Tasha: 才吃了一克糖
Tasha: Only one gram of sugar per person.
其他人:因为我觉得这些太甜了
Others: I think these are too sweet.
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Okay.
Tasha: 那就加5颗糖
Tasha: Then just add 5 pieces of sugar.
其他人:对少搁点就行
Others: Yeah, just a little bit is fine.
Tasha: 太甜了某个人
Tasha: It's too sweet for someone.
Tasha: 哎呦我天
Tasha: Oh my God.
其他人:让我尝一尝这炼乳啥味
Others: Let me taste this condensed milk.
其他人:我去外边做那个蛋挞都这么甜呢加了这么多不健康的东西
Others: When I make egg tarts outside, they're this sweet too, with so many unhealthy ingredients.
Tasha: 是的呢
Tasha: Yeah, that's true.
Tasha: 而且自己做的原料都还是好的原料
Tasha: And the ingredients we use ourselves are still good quality.
Tasha: 外面还可能做那种反式脂肪的原料
Tasha: Outside, they might use those trans-fat ingredients.
Tasha: 就更更容易那个什么了
Tasha: Which makes it even worse.
Tasha: 我刚刚做的那个对
Tasha: The one I just made, yeah.
其他人：那个出锅还要再点缀
Others: It still needs some garnishing after it comes out.
Tasha: 肯定要加肉松呀
Tasha: Definitely need to add some pork floss.
其他人：底筋的面粉出来就是那种
Others: Low-gluten flour gives that texture.
Tasha: 松软的如果是高筋的
Tasha: Soft, if it's high-gluten.
Tasha: 比如说做月饼什么东西的呀
Tasha: Like for making mooncakes or something.
Tasha: 包饺子中筋吧
Tasha: For dumplings, use medium-gluten.
Tasha: 或者普通的低筋也可以
Tasha: Or regular low-gluten is fine too.
Tasha: 我刚说要加什么哦
Tasha: What did I just say to add?
Tasha: 加淡奶油
Tasha: Add some light cream.
Tasha: 糖搁了你就搁了糖
Tasha: You added sugar, right?
Tasha: 还有搁了10克
Tasha: Also added 10 grams.
其他人：还有三个蛋挞给你弄三个鸡蛋
Others: There are three egg tarts, so we need three eggs.
Tasha: 对只要3个蛋黄就行
Tasha: Yeah, just three egg yolks.
其他人：蛋黄ok那蛋白怎么办呢
Others: Okay, what about the egg whites?
Tasha: 蛋白不要了
Tasha: We don't need the egg whites.
Tasha: 或者做舒芙蕾也可以
Tasha: Or we can make soufflé.
Tasha: 一般蛋白就只能用来做舒芙蕾
Tasha: Usually, egg whites can only be used for soufflé.
其他人：这个餐具为啥以前都不洗啊
Others: Why didn't anyone wash these dishes before?
Tasha: 因为洗了太多次了我
Tasha: Because I've washed it too many times.
Tasha: 而且又没有人愿意洗
Tasha: And no one else is willing to wash it.
其他人：他们咋不洗
Others: Why don't they wash it?
Tasha: 他们可能不做饭吧
Tasha: Maybe they don't cook.
Tasha: 我没有瞎说呀
Tasha: I'm not making this up.
Tasha: 无事发生
Tasha: Nothing happened.
Jake:嗯有跑腿是吧
Jake: Hmm, we have a runner, right?
Tasha: 点过啦跑腿
Tasha: Already ordered a runner.
Jake:那我们去取快递
Jake: Then let's go pick up the package.
Tasha: 点了顺丰
Tasha: Ordered SF Express.
Tasha: 顺丰跑腿18
Tasha: SF Express runner, 18.
其他人：多少钱
Others: How much?
其他人：这么贵
Others: So expensive.
Tasha: 可能吧
Tasha: Maybe.
其他人：要三个蛋黄
Others: Need three egg yolks.
Tasha: 对
Tasha: Right.
Tasha: 只要三个蛋黄啊
Tasha: Just three egg yolks?
Tasha: 只要蛋黄
Tasha: Only yolks.
Tasha: 欧丽蛋黄欧丽蛋黄即可
Tasha: Only egg yolks, that's fine.
其他人：这个我要怎么搞呢先把蛋白弄出来
Others: How do I do this? First, separate the egg whites.
Tasha: 你就把蛋白倒进去
Tasha: Just pour the egg whites out.
Tasha: 然后把蛋黄舀进来就行了
Tasha: Then scoop the yolks in, that's it.
Tasha: okay okay
Tasha: Okay, okay.
Tasha: 哎哟我天呐
Tasha: Oh my god.
Tasha: 您真是做饭的一把好手
Tasha: You're really good at cooking.
Tasha: 在家经常做饭吗
Tasha: Do you often cook at home?
Tasha: 在家一看就不经常做
Tasha: Seems like you don't cook often at home.
其他人：我知识不经常做甜品
Others: I don't usually make desserts.
Tasha: 那你经常做饭吗
Tasha: But do you cook often?
其他人：做啊天天做饭
Others: Yeah, cook every day.
Tasha: 是吗
Tasha: Really?
Tasha: 哦
Tasha: Oh.
Tasha: 我也在家经常做饭吃
Tasha: I also cook often at home.
Jake:但我一般都点外卖
Jake: But I usually order takeout.
其他人：卧槽那天我吃完那个米森拌饭以后
Others: Damn, after I had that rice bowl that day,
其他人：回家就点了点了
Others: I went home and ordered it again.
Tasha: 好吃吗是吧
Tasha: Was it good?
其他人：嘿嘿嘿确实还行
Others: Hehe, it was pretty good.
Tasha: 啊是吧
Tasha: Oh, really?
Tasha: 我就爱吃那家饭的鱿鱼
Tasha: I just love the squid from that place.
Tasha: 还有那个儿童餐里面有一个啊
Tasha: And there's one in the kids' meal.
其他人：我哦就点了一个儿童餐的
Others: Oh, I just ordered a kids' meal.
Tasha: 儿童餐的不是金枪鱼
Tasha: The kids' meal isn't tuna.
Tasha: 拌饭的那个
Tasha: It's the mixed rice one.
Tasha: 拌饭叫对
Tasha: The mixed rice, yeah.
其他人：我那天就点了一个牛肉拌饭
Others: That day I ordered the beef mixed rice.
Tasha: 那个好吃
Tasha: That one's tasty.
Tasha: 对我一般就吃这两个
Tasha: Yeah, I usually eat these two.
其他人：但那个感觉有点太挑了都
Others: But it feels a bit picky.
Tasha: 你可以在配料里面不要玉米
Tasha: You can ask for no corn in the ingredients.
其他人：反正我上网搜
Others: Anyway, I searched online.
其他人：能开车吧
Others: Can drive, right?
其他人：不能你得去开车
Others: No, you have to drive.
其他人：为啥你不是叫不
Others: Why don't you just...
其他人：我操走走走
Others: Damn, let's go.
Tasha: 没事没事没事没事没事没事
Tasha: It's okay, it's okay, it's okay.
其他人：他们要去取东
Others: They need to pick up stuff.
Tasha: 哎呦哎呦
Tasha: Oh dear, oh dear.
其他人：你去开车
其他人：为哈呀
Others: Why?
其他人：取麦当劳
Others: To get McDonald's.
Tasha: 麦当劳不是叫过跑腿了吗
Tasha: Didn't we already call for McDonald's delivery?
Jake:没有我我这些东西很多的
Jake: No, I have a lot of these things.
Tasha: 取麦当劳吗
Tasha: To get McDonald's?
Tasha: 麦当劳不是送到门口吗
Tasha: Doesn't McDonald's deliver to the door?
Jake:麦当劳谢谢您
Jake: Thank you, McDonald's.
Tasha: 我选择这里
Tasha: I choose here.
其他人：哦那我们直接走去就行
Others: Oh, then we can just walk there.
Tasha: 走去哪里
Tasha: Walk where?
Jake:驿站
Jake: To the post station.
其他人：麦当劳就一公里还开车取
Others: McDonald's is just a kilometer away, we still need to drive?
Tasha: 麦当劳送到门口了
Tasha: McDonald's delivers to the door.
Jake:咱是要取快递
Jake: We're picking up a package.
Jake:走吧
Jake: Let's go.
Shure: 再见
Shure: Goodbye.
Jake:确实这
Jake: Indeed.
Shure: 不知道啊
Shure: Don't know.
其他人：刘帅贴的吧
Others: Did Choiszt post it?
其他人：啥啊不是啊我不一直在这呆着
Others: What? No, I've been here all the time.
Jake:不是我贴的
Jake: I didn't post it.
Katrina: 不是你吗
Katrina: Wasn't it you?
Jake:不是你吗
Jake: Wasn't it you?
Shure: 真不是我
Shure: It really wasn't me.
Katrina: 调监控
Katrina: Check the surveillance.
Tasha: 这个
Tasha: This one.
Tasha: 鸡蛋羹不得搁
Tasha: You can't put eggs in the steamed egg custard.
Tasha: 搁鸡蛋进去
Tasha: Add the eggs in.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Jake:挖掘三尺
Jake: Dig three feet deep.
Lucia:早知道早知道
Lucia: If only I knew earlier.
Jake:你想想你想想
Jake: Think about it.
Lucia:我就不告诉你了
Lucia: I'm not telling you.
Jake:你贴的时候有没有戴眼镜
Jake: Were you wearing glasses when you posted it?
Lucia:原来你不知道
Lucia: So you didn't know.
Jake:不知道
Jake: Didn't know.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Lucia:哈哈不知道
Lucia: Haha, didn't know.
Shure: 不知道不清楚
Shure: Didn't know, not clear.
Jake:你你想想贴的时候戴没戴眼镜
Jake: Think about it, were you wearing glasses when you posted it?
Shure: 我不知道谁贴的呀
Shure: I don't know who posted it.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
其他人：是不是得等那个弄完了
Others: Should we wait until that's done?
Tasha: 嗯对要等那个做完
Tasha: Yeah, we need to wait until that's done.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahahahaha.
Shure: 什么贴啥
Shure: What are you posting?
Tasha: 我去看看那个
Tasha: I'll go check that.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Lucia:这个安康鱼也是你的吗
Lucia: Is this anglerfish also yours?
Jake:走走走哈哈哈
Jake: Let's go, let's go, hahaha.
Shure: 这是我我们老的队名
Shure: This was our old team name.
Tasha: 这个
Tasha: This one.
Tasha: 就可以让这个蛋挞爆浆
Tasha: This can make the egg tart burst with filling.
Tasha: 你把它搁进去
Tasha: You put it in.
其他人：加糖吗那种焦糖是怎么做的
Others: Do you add sugar? How do you make caramel?
Tasha: 焦糖吗
Tasha: Caramel?
Tasha: 焦糖的话就是在表面的话会用
Tasha: For caramel, you'd use it on the surface.
Tasha: 再再用高火
Tasha: Then use high heat.
其他人：这可以直接吃吗
Others: Can we eat this directly?
Tasha: 可以
Tasha: Yes.
其他人：这有点甜算了
Others: This is a bit sweet, forget it.
其他人：焦糖这有点像代可可脂
Others: This caramel is kind of like cocoa butter substitute.
Tasha: 黑壳
Tasha: Dark shell.
Tasha: 不是代可可脂
Tasha: Not cocoa butter substitute.
Tasha: 纯可可脂
Tasha: Pure cocoa butter.
其他人：你看啊
Others: Look at this.
其他人：反而不是那种巧克力
Others: It's not that kind of chocolate.
其他人：这就一个鸡蛋
Others: It's just one egg.
其他人：还占了壳
Others: And it's taking up the shell.
其他人：这个声是提前明白的
Others: This sound is understood in advance.
Tasha: 绅士鸡蛋
Tasha: Gentleman's egg.
Tasha: 没削好
Tasha: Didn't peel it well.
Tasha: 也都可以直接吃
Tasha: You can eat it directly too.
Tasha: 最终大家一起去取快递了
Tasha: In the end, everyone went to pick up the package together.
其他人：好像是
Others: Seems like it.
其他人：为啥加巧克力
Others: Why add chocolate?
其他人：它会爆浆
Others: It will burst with filling.
其他人：哦你说它回头会爆浆
Others: Oh, you mean it will burst with filling later.
Tasha: 嗯对
Tasha: Yeah, right.
其他人：咬的时候会爆浆
Others: It will burst when you bite it.
其他人：那就那个熔岩什么的
Others: Like that lava thing.
Tasha: 嗯对
Tasha: Yeah, right.
其他人：那他们有
Others: They have it.
其他人：比如熔岩草莓是什么固态的草莓酱
Others: Like lava strawberry, which is solid strawberry jam.
Tasha: 什么
Tasha: What?
其他人：熔岩草莓
Others: Lava strawberry.
Tasha: 没吃过熔岩草莓就是
Tasha: Never had lava strawberry.
其他人：能不能做几个不带这个
Others: Can we make some without it?
Tasha: 那就第一排
Tasha: Then the first row.
其他人：好
Others: Okay.
Tasha: 不带你你匀过去吧
Tasha: Without it, you distribute them.
其他人：多加几个
Others: Add a few more.
Tasha: 好了吗
Tasha: Done yet?
Tasha: 这个好多呀
Tasha: This is a lot.
其他人：   就是要来几个特别多的
Others: Just need a few with a lot.
其他人：我到了
Others: I'm here.
Tasha: 行你倒吧
Tasha: Alright, you pour it.
Tasha: 倒个8分满就行
Tasha: Just fill it 80%.
Tasha: 哎你没关系
Tasha: Hey, no worries.
Tasha: 你就把倒满12个就行
Tasha: Just fill up twelve evenly.
Tasha: 均匀一点即可
Tasha: Just make it even.